Super Bass is a powerful open source
alternative to Google's Firebase in this
beginner's course giyum will help you
get up and running with Super Bass this
course aims to equip you with the
Knowledge and Skills necessary to
efficiently build modern secure web
applications using super bases robust
features you'll dive into the essentials
of leveraging real-time databases insta
apis and super bases authentication and
authorization capabilities whether
you're an aspiring developer or a
seasoned professional looking to expand
your toolkit this course will help you
streamline back-end development with
Super Bass hello everybody and welcome
to this course about Super Bass I'm
really excited to introduce you to my
favorite product of the year because
it's been a long time that I was waiting
for a product that will do the same as
Firebase but with postgres and so SQL
base it's an open source alternative to
Firebase and other Firebase users since
many years I was waiting for that since
a long time with super bay is what you
can do basically it's to create tables
but also you can have a notification
system a storage system and everything
that is provided by postgres on one
click you can create a backend as a
service and that's really great for
people who wants to create project
really fast but also with Super Bass you
can create projection project because
Super Bass is built on top of postgres
so you have all the benefits of postgres
and also you have all the benefits of a
real back end because you can use also
the real time and you can use for
instance the edge function so in this
complete course I'm going to teach you
how to deal with Super Bass to create a
backend on one click and to launch your
project right away or to choose the best
alternative for your clients for
instance or for your startup here is the
program of our course first we are going
to learn how to create a project so how
to sign in sign up or to plug it to your
application for instance
then we are going to look at the tables
because Super Bass is built on top of
progress so of course we can create
tables and everything that is around it
policies raw level security
etc etc
so there is also a chapter on row level
security to understand what is it
exactly and how to use it
there is a chapter also on
authentication or to deal with
authentication because Super Bass has a
full system to deal with authentication
and with the SDK it's so fast to install
we will talk also about user management
recover password email templates and
email templates this is something that I
love about Super Bass when a user is
going to sign in or sign up it will
receive an email automatically from
Super Bass you don't have to do it and
you can work also on the templates of
those emails
we will enter in the real subject of
using a backend so we will talk about
read insert delete or update elements
rows in your tables but also in storage
for instance we will talk about
subscriptions we will talk about
relation between table because it's SQL
so we can do relation with Super Bass
we will talk about functions triggers
schema storage logs because it's a
backend of course we want to know if
something went wrong we will want to
have some feedback and we're going to
use for that the logs
we will talk about extensions real time
Edge functions and we will see that edge
functions are really useful and finally
finally we will talk about web books
which is really really cool to use
because for instance every time you're
going to add some data to a table you
want to perform an action we can do that
with WebEx it was an example we can do
way more but we are going to see all of
these together so if you are ready to
create a project with Super Bass right
now and to learn everything you need to
know to create a backend as a service in
some minutes let's go let's work
together on that
welcome to this new course about Super
Bass I'm really really excited to
introduce you to my favorite product of
the year
why because actually Super Bass is a
backend as a service on one click and it
really helps you to bootstrap your
application really fast
so what is Super Bass
as I said it's a backend as a service it
means that you can create a project on
the platform and actually you can have a
notification system that helps you to
deal with all the providers such as
Google LinkedIn GitHub whatever and you
can actually help on your front-end
application to log in through those
providers
but also there is a database and this
database is running on postgres
and you can create table make
relationships triggers everything that
is around postgres because Super Bass
has been built on postgres so there are
really big fans of postgres and
everything that is available under
postgres is available on Super Bass
but also with Super Bass you can have
Edge functions that helps you to run
some application on the backend side
such as a dino server for instance you
can have real-time subscriptions also of
course there is Storage and one of the
features that I like the most is that
you have a documentation that generates
depending on your table all the code
that you need for your SDK on the
front-end side but we are going to see
all of this in this long course about
Super Bass and I really hope you're
gonna enjoy
so basically when we arrive on the
website of Super Bass
we have some explanation of what is
Super Bass you have some
testimonies and Etc you get some code
and we clearly see that it's really easy
to implement really fast because you
just have to install the SDK or Super
Bass use the create client and then you
can use it and there's a lot of other
things but what we want to do we want to
create a new project right away we want
to have our backend as a service under
Super Bass so to start it's totally free
okay it's free and up to 500 megabytes
of database and one giga of file storage
so we have a a big size that is
available on us on the hard drive to
build a project okay so to bootstrap a
startup it is really ideal that's the
best you have also two gigabytes of
bandwave etc etc 50 000 monthly active
user
etc etc if you want a GoPro on Pro you
have a bigger database of course and you
have more services for only 25 dollar
per month honestly for this price this
is the best deal ever you can have
because you can have an almost unlimited
I mean 2 million ad function invocation
000 monthly active users and this is
really big
etc
etc so to start Super Bass is free so
what we're gonna do we are going to
click here on the top on start your
project and we are going to create
immediately our project
so when you click on sign up and you
arrive on get started there is two
possibilities you can either log in with
GitHub so it will be related to your
GitHub instance otherwise you can add
your email and password so what I'm
going to do me I'm going to connect with
an email and a password to have a fresh
instance on super bass once we are
logged in we arrive on a dashboard and
on this dashboard you can find the
project but also the organization
so you can have several projects on the
free plan you are supposed to have
maximum two projects and one project
contains a whole actually project of
Super Bass with everything inside so the
authentication the database the storage
etc etc
you can have also several organizations
and on those organizations of course we
understand that we can have several
projects
also you have everything that is related
to your account the preference the
access token you can log out you get the
API reference also but we are not going
to wait that much we are going to click
on new project because we are here to
create a new project
and this is where we are going to set up
everything
so I arrived here on this uh pop-up
creating a new project and here I can
select my organization also what I can
do is to put the name of this project so
I can put my new Super Bass project okay
and I'm supposed to have a database
password okay so basically this password
should be very strong because it's
supposed to be for the database this is
why they provide to you here a button
generator password that you can use
and what I propose you to do is to copy
paste this password somewhere okay so
you got to keep this password it's
really really important also there is
the region so here we got to create
actually an instance and on this
instance we have several regions several
servers that we can check I'm going to
stay on North Virginia and down there
you have the pricing plan and that's
what we saw before you can choose the
pro or you can stay on the free so for
this demonstration I'm going to take a
free plan even if on my own instance I
got a Pro Plan here we can work with a
free plan to show what is exactly Super
Bass and there we go my project has been
created
so we see here that it's setting up the
project on the server once it will be
done we will get access to all the
features of Super Bass that are here on
the left so we can already see that we
have a table editor so we will see that
just after the SQL editor so there is an
SQL editor there a database an
authentication system the storage The
Edge functions the reports the logs the
API Docs
and on there we got the project settings
here on this page what we've got we've
got a link directly to documentation
there so if I open the documentation
here I arrive on everything that is
related to Super Bass and how to use it
and this dock guys is brand new thanks
to the Super Bass team it's a really
really nice Dock and it's really
efficient at the same time so you get
guides if you want to integrate Super
Bass with react nextgs flutter because
Super Bass works a lot with flutter view
solid GS velkit etc etc you get also
documentation on database art storage
real time so super bass fought about
everything they are making a product for
people who don't want necessarily to
create a backend or work on it on just
having the skills to do it so they
design and they wrote a very nice
documentation that goes straight to the
point
so if you want to have more information
next to my courses you can click for
instance on here on database and down
there you get a lot of examples of the
tables that we are going to see after on
how to use the database if you want to
go too hot it's exactly the same you
even have videos and here there is the
CTO and Wilson that is talking to you
about Earth here we see that we can log
in with email magic Link phone social
login etc etc okay there is a lot of
documentation like this we can come back
to it later and there we go back on the
project we see that we have an analytics
part on the database request on the
authentication storage and stuff so
there is also inside the product
an analytics part that is very
interesting to have an overview every
day on your product if it is working or
not etc etc
if you are using different client
libraries you also have guides about it
on JavaScript python or flutter of
course everything here is really clear
to handle and if I go on table editor we
can see here that we can create tables
that's what we're going to see in the
next lesson there is an SQL editor but
of course Super Bass know that not
everybody knows how to work with SQL so
they build a very smart system for me
that is a script system that helps you
to actually create a script
with a starter actually this is the
starters that you can use if you want to
have a script on show extensions an
incremental field value to add a colon
of course and there is even a user
management starter that is very very
useful and that maybe most of you will
use because if you don't know postgres
and if you don't know how to write SQL
you will maybe have some trouble to deal
with creating a user management system
you can just click on this and there we
go it creates for you in the SQL editor
all the command to create your table's
profile and also it's creating a with
the row level security and we are going
to come back on this later it's creating
all the policies that are locking the
access of your database if you want that
your tables are not public you can use
policies that are there otherwise if you
want them to be available for people
that are authentified everything has
been thought to make your life easier
okay
also you get the a database here tab
when you can access tables triggers
function extensions etc etc
you get the authentication system that
we are going to see also with all the
providers and look with Super Bass you
can offer to your clients to log in with
bitbucket Discord Facebook git lab
there's a lot of options there there are
also email template things that helps
you to deal with somebody is going to
sign up or if you are going to invit a
user because we can invit people a magic
link that helps us to log in without a
password that is amazing the change
email address the reset password you can
go to storage and on storage here it's
all about the assets image documents
whatever
and there is also the edge functions
there is the reports because there you
can create reports about your back end
you got the logs and of course the logs
for an API it's really really important
and finally you get the API
documentation that here it is going to
generate for you all the code related to
your tables you understood Super Bass is
a complete product that is amazing I
could talk during hours about it
it will help us to bootstrap a product
this backend as a service will save us a
lot of time
Super Bass is working with postgres and
with postgres we can create databases
those databases are made with tables
so we are going to create now a table
and I'm going to explain to you
everything you have to know about tables
so here I can click on table editor here
on the left and when I arrive there is
no table yet of course because we didn't
create any table
so we are going to click on create a new
table but before if you look on the
right on the left sorry
we can see that we got a first option
which is the schema and if we look at it
we see that we have different schema so
for now we are going to stay on the
schema public and I will come back later
to explain to you what are schemas
so you can create as much table as you
want and all those tables will be
displayed here on the left
a table what is this well actually a
table it's a simple table with rows and
columns and they are going to Define
some kind of business logic or some kind
of data it will Define actually the
model of what you want to create
so we need to create tables to store our
data
so I'm going to click on new table and
we see here that I got this form that is
opening on the right
and here I can start to create my new
table under the public schema
so first I gotta give a name and this
name I suggest you to write it in come
in a snake case it's really important
so what I'm going to do here I'm going
to create several tables with several
models and the first table that I'm
going to create is a table clients okay
I want to store clients and on the
description I can put a table to store
my clients all right
so we have
that is checked and it's returned
recommended
so enable raw security we will have a
full listen on it
it is restricting the access to your
table by enabling this mode so basically
with the raw level security in your
table your database will not be
accessible
until you will write policies on
postgres so we will need later to write
policies to make our table accessible
so we are going to let that check
we are not going to enable real time the
enable real-time option is to broadcast
the changes on the table and we are
going to start right away by creating
the model of our clients
so we can see here that we've got a
little editor and we've got columns with
name
type default value and primary and also
we've got this cross to just remove this
element
and we've got options here when we click
on it we see that we got extra options
here this is the the model of your data
all right so you got to create columns
to define the model of clients
also what you can do here we see that we
get an option to import the data via
spreadsheet
all right so let's create the model of
our clients
there is an ID here and we can see also
that it's snake case convention
and what I can do is I can change if you
want the name and later we'll add new
columns here I see that I got a little
button when I click on it we see that
it's to add a foreign key for ID
so we will also look at this later what
we want to do is to create the model for
now
so there is a type and when I click on
type we can see that super bass is
providing to me all the postgres data
type that I can add to my specific row
so here it's ID
so we can see that I get integers
floats numeric
Json
text uuid that date and timestamps and
of course booleans so here I'm going to
choose uuid and if I go on the official
documentation of postgres on
postgresql.org I can find that postgres
is providing to me functions
that are generating different kind of
uuid and here we can find the function
that is integrated to superbase the uuid
generate V4 that generate a version for
uuid which is derived entirely from
random numbers
so in postgres and by extension in Super
Bass
with get function that help us to
trigger some generations or some actions
so here I'm going to click here and it's
going to be the primary key so for those
who don't know postgres the primary key
this is the key that is going to help us
to index our element and to find it
through the postgres engine
all right so our client will get an ID
there will be also a created ad which is
a timestamp and here we can find again
the function now
so now it's again a function provided by
postgres to give us the current date and
time all right
however this client will have more than
this any I would like to add actually
here a new column it will be an email
column
and I don't get any type email here so
what I can put is text okay I want to
add a text and there we go
however the thing is that I want that on
my database client
every client here
should have an email if there is no
email I want to prevent to enter a
client I don't want to have to have a
client that is generated without an
email because I cannot identify him only
with the ID I would like to identify him
with the email so what I can do is to
click here
and when I click here we see that
I got these extra options open and I got
the option is nullable
so when I check this I allow that email
would be null on insert and that's not
what I want so I'm going to remove it
and also I want that this email would be
unique because on my list of clients I
don't want to have different clients
with the same email I would like to
prevent this I can do it
so if I want to add a client without an
email I will get an error and if I want
to add a client that is already in my
list I will have an error also
so I'm going to click on this there we
go I get an ID I created ad and an email
all right
so let's say that we are going to stay
on this for now I'm going to click on
Save I'm going to save the tables client
it's going to add the three columns to
the clients table and now there we go
our table clients is good to go so we
are ready to use it and we see that it
takes the form actually exactly like a
spreadsheet so we got columns
and we can insert elements and also what
we got here we see that we get a plus if
we want to add a new column to our model
it's all of course possible
congratulations you got your first table
clients we've got several options we see
that we get refresh which is very useful
because we don't want to refresh all the
browser we can refresh just the table we
can then filter sort the client so let's
imagine we will have thousands of
clients we can do it right away on Super
Bass and this is something that I like
we can talk about it for a second
this is something that I like a lot with
supervisors that it's visual so when you
are building a company and one once you
have a backend you must have a back
office for your company a search as for
the marketing department for
um the clients everything that is
related actually to non-technical
departments well with super bay is your
marketing department can come here and
look at the data when they need
something instead of requesting all the
time uh actually the backend developer
to to have the state of the data so it's
very useful you don't have to code it
it's right away there what I'm gonna do
I'm going to click on insert and here we
see that we get two options insert row
and insert column so inside column it's
exactly the same as this plus there
so I'm going to click on insert row and
there we go I got a new form and here we
see that I can insert a client all right
so what I'm going to do I'm going to
click on Save right away I'm not going
to fulfill anything
and what's gonna happen of course is
that I'm going to have my first error on
Super Bass
violates not new constraint remember
email
of clients
cannot be known so I have to enter a
value so what I'm going to do I'm going
to enter a value so it's going to be
called with Geon at gmail.com there we
go and on the uuid I don't need to put
anything the function is going to
generate it for me as well as for the
created ad and there we go I got my
first entry inside my clients table
let's say that I'm going to add a new
row and this time it's going to be and
Wilson at superbass.com I'm going to
save
there we go I got another one so as you
see I can later consult here my
um actually my um my data and changing
right away because under this I'm
totally super admin so I can change
everything
and here I forgot to put actually I
forgot to put one column so I can click
here and add a new colon and this one is
going to be is active
and the description will be defined
if client is active Okay I can add a
foreign key relation we're going to do
it later another type I'm going to put
Boolean
all right and it cannot be null and by
default is going to be on true
what's going to happen here and when I'm
going to click on Save
is that it's going to add okay the
column is active and put the default
value to all the members all right good
now let's say that I'm going to try to
add a new client but with the same email
I'm going to click here I'm going to
type this and when I click on Save
I got another error which is totally
legit it violates the unique constraint
clearance email key because Andrew is
already existing inside my database okay
we've got the table clients now let's
create a new table and this one is going
to be a table orders orders by the
clients by clients actually
there we go we enable row level security
we do exactly the same I'm going to use
uuid then I'm going to use the generated
ad and here what I'm going to do I want
to add a client ID for the future and
this one is going to be uuid also
and here I'm not going to put the
generator because I want to fulfill by
an existing client ID
so here I'm going to put that it's not
nullable because I don't want my orders
to have an empty client ID
so I'm going to save this
ID created that client ID let's say that
we're gonna have some kind of price and
there what I can put is just let's say a
numeric okay for now let's say numeric
we allow it to be null for the moment
and what I can have also with this as an
order is client ID price we can say a
lot of other stuff like such address
and there here what I can put is
actually a text okay here we Define the
address because it's supposed to be
related to the client but maybe the
client will put a different address so
if we store the address in the client we
will have trouble later we want to
relate the address to an order okay
so address and let's put the ZIP code
okay we've got the zip code and again
I'm going to put the text of course I
could put varsha the variable length
character string but here I'm just going
to put this ZIP code and city and I'm
going to put this let's say text and
there we go so we've got
Clay on tidina and we need of course we
need the name because if we don't get
any name for the order it will be
terrible so created that client ID price
address ZIP code order there we go so
I'm going to click on save so now I'm
not using uh any SDK with any app
so what I need to do is to take an
existing client ID so let's say that I'm
going to take mine so here I got an ID a
uuid I'm going to save
and to create my order I need
a uuid so I'm going to insert a row and
here I'm going to put as an ID this one
there we go then as a price I'm going to
put let's say uh yeah 20 there we go the
address I'm going to say
um one two three uh Super Bass Road
there we go as the ZIP code a890 there
we go City Super Bass and the name is
going to be code with Guillaume and I
can put anything I want here
I'm going to save and there we go I got
my first order with my clients that I
can use for now
so you see we can create tables really
fast we can have as much table I just
created those two tables as an example
but just imagine that later you will
have a lot of tables and we will succeed
later to create relations between the
tables to actually deal to actually deal
with fetching the data at once and not
fetching the clients than the order etc
etc
but we are going to see this after
because right now our table is not
active because we didn't edit the RLS
policies the raw level security policies
it's time for us to talk about raw level
security the security feature offered by
postgres to allow the usage or the
access of our database essentially it
means that the user has to configure all
the access by writing security policies
to all the tables that are created to
all the rows of our tables for example
an administrator can create a policy to
allow access to the table to everybody
but to restrict actually to write on
this table or to delete some elements on
the official documentation of postgresql
we have more information about raw
security policies
and I'm not going to read the old
article you can find it on
postgresql.org
however we have some interesting text
here that we can read together
in addition to the SQL standard
privilege system available through Grant
tables can have raw security policies
that restrict on a per user basis which
rows can be returned by normal queries
by inserted updated or deleted by data
modification commands
this feature is also known as row level
security by default and this is the case
on the table that we created
tables do not have any policies so let's
get back to our tables there and we can
click here on clients for instance and
we can click here on orders so right now
we've got one holder and of course those
orders they could not be fetched by a
user that is not authentified and it
could not be fetched by somebody else
than the user that wants to fetch it so
to write my first row level policy what
I can do is either to click here on no
active errorless policies
either going here on authentication and
go on policies and here we got the list
of the tables and we've got the option
concerning rollover security again if
you want to have more information you
can either click here on the rollover
security button that we have here what
is your level security and you got more
explanation here on the official
documentation of Super Bass here we've
got the clients we've got the orders
okay so let's create a new policy
because for now we want to restrict the
access so when you click on new policy
you can do two things you can use
actually the templates provided by Super
Bass and this is very useful for the
people who don't know anything about SQL
or you can click on full customization
to create a policy from scratch so I'm
going to click on this at first
and here we see that we have a form
again and we can enter the policy's name
we can click here on select insert
update delete all to select actually
which is the operation that you want to
do and you can also Target the roles so
we can see here and we discover now that
in Super Bass every user can have a role
that we can Define okay so here we've
got Anon so Anon we understand it's four
anybody actually authenticated it will
be for people authenticated through the
authentication system and after you got
other roles etc etc
and down there you can provide a SQL
condition expression that Returns the
Boolean
all right so if you know SQL it will be
very easy for you to create your policy
through here but if you click here on
view template okay there you can have
four template for now on creating
policies
so for the actually we are looking right
now on the clients and on the template
we see that here we've got one template
that says enable read access to everyone
so here we get the SQL template
that gives this policy and it will
enable the read access to everyone
it says create policy policy name so
here you're supposed to have the name of
your policy which will be actually
enabled in access to everyone
on public which is the schema ah
actually we are on the schema public and
we created uh tables on the schema
public
dot clients which is the name of the
table
for select using with the condition true
which means that anybody
is able to select so to read
every element of clients
so if you want to do that you click on
use this template and you will actually
release your table clients to the rid of
anybody it's like the unknown condition
that's something we don't want to do on
the clients
then we have enable insert access for
authenticated user only so here we've
got another SQL query and we can see
that this policy gives insert access to
your table to all authenticated user
only
so it would create the policy again on
the table clients for insert 2
authenticated which is the role okay
with check true so we want to use this
one so what I'm going to do I'm going to
click on use this template and suddenly
I'm getting back to the form of the full
customization and it's totally fulfilled
and we can see here okay we can see that
actually what's happening is that it has
fulfilled the old form with the insert
authenticated role with a condition
which is true
so I'm going to click on review
finally I'm reviewing the policy to be
created on publix.clients and there we
go I got my policy and if I click on
Save policy
here we see that I got one policy on
client which concerns insert on
authenticated
so right now
you can insert clients only if you are
authentified alright we want to do the
same with order so what I can do is to
click on here on get started and I can
do exactly the same because it's a
template so now on order it will be only
for people authentified
okay
however this is a problem what I'm doing
now because I'm not sure that I want to
create
directly here like this this way
the thing is that I would like to have
later a trigger that will create an
order automatically
for this course I'm just going to click
on review and save this policy because I
just want to show you the example on how
to add a holder directly this way
from the front end but normally I
wouldn't do this way I would use a
trigger to do it there we go so now
we've got the clients we've got the
order and we've got our two policies and
in the future as much tables you will
have you will have to write all the time
do policies concerning those table and
you have to be really careful on that
guys because you have to really deal
with the fact that sometimes if you do
mistakes your tables could be public and
you don't want that
so let's pretend that now I want to give
access to everybody
I want to give access to everybody to my
clients so if I do it okay
now anybody that could connect to the
database would have to select
publicly all the clients you will be
able to read all the clients however
this is something that I don't want to
have so I want to delete and I'm going
to click here and I'm going to click on
delete you can of course delete your
policies that's really really important
so that's good but
that I don't want that everybody
could read the clients I just want some
people to do it so I'm going to click
again and of course I didn't told you
but of also what you have to do is to
deal with the update and the delete
access to the elements so here I'm
supposed to add clients through an
application so I want to update them
maybe I will have a button to click and
click on modify exactly like I did
before
so if I click here I should add this
condition and we can see that on the odd
GW WT sorry
I got this condition which is using
expression that's so cool that's what I
want to do I want to update with only
the email actually that is related
to the current actually element
so we enable the update for users based
on email okay I'm going to save this and
I'm going to add this policy and of
course you can add as much policies as
you want
I'm going to continue and I want also to
delete I want to also delete
actually the clients that I can have and
here we see that we got something else
we got this condition what uid is equal
to user underscore ID
so I'm going to keep this using this
expression there and I'm going to review
and save the policy
and here I got a problem because I don't
get actually the colon user ID on my
clients
so I'm going to close this I'm going to
get back we need to go on the table
editor on clients and here as I see I
don't get user ID
and that is a problem
that I didn't solve at first is that
many users
will have their clients in the client's
database but they are not related to a
specific user ID
so what I can do here is to add actually
a colon user ID
and this user ID would be actually the
owner's ID of the client
okay
so what I can do there is to say it's
going to be a uuid
and what is going to be this user ID
well I think it's going to be the user
ID of the authenticated user so I'm
going to save this
I don't allow nullable and I don't Hello
is unique because I can have several
clients I'm going to save that and
suddenly I have a problem
because I'm supposed to have at least
okay I'm supposed to have at least
one user ID in the column and we see
that right now it's null for a lot of
them so for now I'm I'm clicking on
allow nullable and it's going to work
and there we go but what I should do is
to fulfill the right user ID of those
two clients which would be mine however
I don't have for now so I'm just going
to delete those two rows and I'm going
to just come back after and when I will
add a new client I would need this user
ID to change my table I can go on
database and on tables I go to clients
okay so here I get clients I can click
here on five columns and I got my user
id there and I'm going to click here and
this time I'm going to remove alone
nullable because in the future I really
want this user ID
okay so I got my user ID and now I can
come back to write my policy back in the
policy I'm going to click here new
policy and what I want to do actually is
to go here and the access that I had
before it's this delete template so I'm
going to use it but I'm not going to use
it as delete I'm going to use it
actually to select
enable select for base for user based on
user ID
and actually here it's going to be
automatic authenticated sorry
every time I'm going to select clients
from the table client
it has to be related with my user ID
what does it mean it means simply
that
our table clients will be full of
different clients coming from you from
me from any anybody
but it it's not possible that I can
fetch your clients we want that you you
can fetch only your clients and me I'm
fetching only my clients
so what we do we enable the select for
for clients so it's not using
based on user ID so I'm going to select
the clients only on my user ID on
authenticated and this odd dot uid
function is will come actually from the
authenticated session that we will have
and then I'm going to click on Save
policy and there we go I got everything
that I need for clients I should do
exactly the same for orders but I think
you understood by this a quick exercise
that you have to work on Raw level
security if you want to secure your
database if you want to secure your
Super Bass instance and especially on
tables where you don't want the public
to get access on later we will see that
if you get an API you can have a certain
role to get all the access to all
databases because here in this case we
don't want our user to get access and to
create orders we would like to have a
trigger or an API to do it the rule
level security help the administrator to
create policies to secure your super
base data base
it is time for us now to look at
authentication with Super Bass
right now we've got two tables clients
and orders and we've got row level
security policies written however later
in our application we would like to have
some kind of authentication system that
allows us to log in or log out from our
session well with Super Bass it's
totally possible to create an
authentication system so when you click
here on authentication you arrive on
this dashboard and on this table and
here we see that we've got a list of
user with email phone provider created
last signing user ID all right
so here our table is totally empty up
there we've got reload button and also
invit and if I click on invit here
I have a pop-up and this pop-up is
showing to me an input with a user image
so if I'm putting geom88 for instance at
jobmail.com and I click on invit user
Super Bass will send an email to invite
this user to join and while this user
will click on the button to join what
you will get is just here a status of
waiting for verification so as we can
see the user here has been created so we
don't need actually in Super Bass to
create a table user here I mean you
could do it for further information
about the user and there is a template
actually called user management a SQL
script template that is creating a
profile that a table to put more
information but basically at first Super
Bass is providing to us this here this
list of users so right now we should go
on this email and look at what Super
Bass sent to us alright I'm on the email
and here we can see that I have an
invitation and I have a button that is
click the invite however it says that I
need to actually redirect to a local
3000 to validate my user that's what
we're gonna do actually we will use a
template A View application
two displayed our authentication system
so the user will receive this email we
click there and it will be redirected to
localhost 3000 however when it will be
on production we will have to change
this URL because right now we would like
that this email goes to the production
URL not localhost well we can do it here
by clicking on URL configuration so you
get the sit URL redirection of course
but you got here the Ctrl that will be
provided directly into the email
now Super Bass give us the opportunity
to edit the email template on several
case
and if we click here on in which user we
can see that we've got the email
template down there
we've got several other options however
I will come back to this later on
another lesson
on our application we will give the
possibility to login with your email and
here on providers we can see that we've
got the email provided however we get
several other options that allows us to
give the possibility to the user to log
in with other providers such as Google
so when I click on Google we can see
here that I have to provide a client ID
and a client secret and I can click up
there on Google enabled I'm not going to
show you how to connect with all those
providers but basically you have to go
on the documentation of every of them
and create an app on the developer site
to get the keys related to The
Connection by those providers so right
now we've got this email that's good now
we would like to have a front-end
application where we could actually
create a connection I have created for
you a vgs free application with an
authentication system in order to use
Super Bass
I didn't show you how to code it because
on my channel there is already a video
to code actually the authentication
system from a vgs application to
Superbass I also have a video about this
with nexgs you can go check it out but
for now we are going to work with this
application
so right now I got a login here form and
we can see up there that I if I change
the url and I go on any other route I
will never move from the main page
so find the repository into the
description and once you've cloned it
you're right in here and so it's a basic
vue.gs free application with terrain CSS
we have our Super Bass client here that
is coming from the Super Bass GS SDK and
again if you want more information about
Hearth you can go on Super Bass dock on
half everything is explained there to
work with authentication me I did the
whole work just for you so it will be
faster video credentials to access to
your Super Bass project you can go down
there on Project settings you click on
API and here you've got your key your
actually your secret key and down there
you get the service wall that allows you
actually to do everything so be safe
take this one for the user and the URL
is up there so remember if I go on here
on the API docs I can go to
authentication up there and I have the
keys that I need or I have the elements
that I need to set up the authentication
itself okay but if I click on user
management here we can see that we've
got data uh super
bass.signup and we can use actually we
can use those elements to login
so we can see also which is cool is that
we can log in with magic link via email
this is exactly what we did before we
send an email and there is a magic link
we don't need any password and we can
log in just by email so what I did here
is just to bind my values email and
password to a model
and I have a function login and it's
really simple actually I'm calling Super
Bass dot hearth.signup Super Bass it's
the client that I have initiated here
I'm cutting it directly from the SDK I'm
calling dsdk with the function signup
coming from the documentation with email
and password so I put login here but
actually it's sign up okay so I'm going
to take sign up instead of login there
we go I'm going to save get back I'm
going to update and I'm going to click
on sign in and for now nothing is
happening however I'm going to get back
to Earth and I'm going to reload up
there and when I click on reload there
we go I got my user there before going
on the email I'm going to open my
console and up there I'm going to click
on confirm your email once I click I'm
redirected directly to my application on
localhost 3000
and I got here the user so we can see we
got the access token we got the refresh
token the token type and we've got down
there the full user and I'm going to
reload and we can see that now my user
is not waiting for any verification
so what we did in this lesson well it's
basically really simple to understand
we have a front-end application where we
installed super bass and we are using
this SDK of Super Bass and we initiated
our client we are credentials okay
and what we did is just to set
our main file
the authenticated system that says that
if there is no user
we just show login if there is a user we
show all the other pages and oh do we
check this user by using the on odd
State change from coming from Super Bass
SDK that returns a session to us
immediately so we don't need to set up
any token we don't need to do any art
with a GWT token because everything is
already done with the Super Bass SDK so
we actually win a lot of time we save a
lot of time by using this SDK we don't
need to work on the authentication
system
Superbass is dealing with it and it is
recording for us automatically our users
on the example with the authentication I
just show you to sign up of course you
would have to create a second form which
will be about login because if we look
at the documentation and here on the
user management side of the
documentation on API docs on the left
we can see that we've got a user signup
method that we used but also we got down
there a user login so of course you
would have to use a second form I didn't
do it in a template but you can do it
which is really cool with Super Bass is
that the user management is super easy
you have several ways to sign up or log
in your users
and basically we've got here a quick
explanation
super bass makes it easy to manage your
user Super Bass assigns each user a
unique ID you can reference this ID
anywhere in your database
this is why we created before on the
tables listen
a colon with user ID because when we
will log in as a user we will get our ID
and we will store it into our context
into our session and we will be able
actually to use this user ID to fetch
data from the tables
so here we've got the user ID that is
available okay
so what we can do we can sign up we
already saw it before we can log in with
email and password
we can login with magic link via email
so this is really the my favorite
feature of Super Bass is that you don't
need to worry about storing crypted
passwords or stuff like this which is a
very bad practice in my opinion
but what you can do here with Super Bass
is just to log in via email and it's
really easy so how does it work because
I got this question all the time well
actually you send a user a passwordless
link which they can use to redeem an
access token after they have clicked on
the link all interaction using Super
Bass GS client will be performed as that
user and which is cool is that you don't
need to code your own system to store
your access token inside the cookie or
in local storage or whatever you don't
need to do it the SDK is going to do it
for you which is really really easy to
handle
and at the same time it's really
Pleasant because with the on odd State
change method that we are going to see
just after again
it's going to work by itself you don't
need to do anything you do not need to
write extra code like all the time which
is boring and you save a lot of time
you can also sign up with phone and
that's a cool feature you can log in Via
SMS you can verify an SMS
and down there you get also other option
to get the user to actually to get a
forgotten password email that we are
going to see after
update your own user here however to get
more information about the user you
would not store them here but in a table
um in a third table like a profile table
for instance and you've got of course
the log out there so if I get back to my
application
and if I update okay what we can see is
that
actually every time I'm logged in my on
odd stage change function is sending me
to the main uh actually to the main page
so what we would like to do is to sign
out so you can use all those functions
to create your own system you can either
propose the option to for the user to
invit other users down there me what I
want to do I want to log out so I got
this Adder up there
and what I'm going to do I'm going to
just
create this quick function call logout
so it's going to be actually it's going
to be sign out which will be an
asynchronous function
and it will be trigger on click on this
button sign out so here I get sign out
there we go so I got my Super Bass
instance which is there so I'm going to
import so Super Bass from actually here
at Super Bass there we go and what I
just need to do is to go here and to
copy paste this piece of code so I'm
going to move this this way there we go
I'm just going to copy paste this so I'm
going to put here my sign out I'm not
going to handle anything it's just to
show you I finally implemented the
authentication system that I wanted I
have the login form and I got the sign
up form
so right now I'm an existing user so I'm
going to click on login and what's
happening there is that I arrive on my
application and I'm logged in now I'm
going to click on sign out up there and
when I click on sign out there we go I'm
logged out so I can try to go on any
page I want it's not going to work you
can find this template in the
description we see that with Super Bass
we've got a very easy user management
system that help us to implement the
authentication that we want
a very common case is to forgot your
password
and Super Bass as a method to help you
to recover your password
on the official documentation we've got
forgotten password email here and we can
see that we have this method reset
password for email
we only need the email of your user to
recover the password however how does it
work well it's really easy
you have first to get a recover page so
here on my application on The View
application that you can find in the
comments down below
you have here a recover page and on this
recover page which looks like this
you've got an email to enter and a send
method I'm using this method here reset
password for email and it's going to
trigger uh actually an email that is
going to be sent from Super Bass to the
current email okay
then once logged in you should direct
the user to a new password form
so basically from here when I'm going to
enter my email and we can look a little
bit at the code what I did here I just
looked at the validate email method that
we've got so if you go on the composable
we've got this method that help us to
check first if it's an email or not so
if we get here and then we click we see
that we've got an arrow if we don't
enter a basic email also if we try to
trigger it with something else it's not
going to work here it's going to work so
I'm not going to trigger it
it's going to call reset password for
email from the model that we've got down
here
so we will receive receive an email that
help us to recover the password however
this is not the end of the process
actually before you should create
another route and this route is supposed
to be an update Route so basically here
we've got this view which tell us to
update our user and it said here you
should use a update user view below to
save the new password and down there
we've got this solution
we've got this update user method this
update user method should be in another
view then you'll recover View so I'm
just created under the profile folder an
update view which does exactly the same
as the recover except that we call the
update user method and we pass the email
and a new password
all right so basically it does almost
the same but here this is the view that
will be actually in the link of the
email
so we need to change the link of our
email so what I'm going to do I'm going
to go on email templates here and I'm
going to go on reset password because
this is where I want to lead and
remember me I got a specific pass
and on my application the specific pass
is profile slash update if I go on my
router here my update profile so my
update user is on the pass profile
update
so remember the confirmation URL and I
will make another listen just after on
this here leads to localhost 3000 but me
I want to go on localhost 3000 slash
profile slash update
so what I need to do is to put here on
my reset password slash profile slash
update because the link
on my email has to go to this pass later
we will change the confirmation URL for
the projection URL
so what I can do here is to use the
email of the current user
or if I want I can click here and click
on send password recovery so I'm just
going to copy paste this and I'm going
to use my app of course because I
created it for the for this
so I get back here I'm going to put this
and when I click loading
successfully reset password
so I'm going to go on my email I'm going
to update
and I just received an email and I got a
click here and when I'm going to click
here we are going to look at the pass I
just open my URL and as you can see I've
been redirected immediately up there so
what I need to do here is to type the
same email as I had so I had this one
okay yup made.com
and under here I'm going to put my new
password okay I'm going to click on
update and there we go I am successfully
updated in short I have a recover page
with the method reset password email I
enter my email I click on send it's
going to send me an email but before I
need to go on reset password on the
authentication email template Tab and
put the link where I want to lead my
reset password link to once it's done I
receive an email I click on reset
password on reset password I arrive on
the page to update my password I can
click and save my new password
on every applications it's always the
same when we had users we want to send
an email to say hi welcome or when they
subscribe we want to confirm their sign
up another case when we recover the
password we want to send an email to
recover the password and lead to the
front-end application
with Super Bass we can do that inside
our dashboard and we've got the options
just here so right now I'm on the
authentication tab where I can deal with
all the users that are recorded inside
my Super Bass application
I can also invit some user if I want
with their email but what I want to deal
with is this email templates
and which is really cool
with Super Bass it's that here we've got
access to the template of five different
email cases and we can insert our own
HTML with here we've got our variable
that we can use and of course some very
often we need the confirmation URL we've
got a pre-written template and that's
really cool because Super Bass here for
instance on confirm sign up
is going to send automatically this
email to the person who is going to
subscribe to the application another
case if we Envy the user we've got some
text already written here with the
confirmation URL
for the magic Link login it's the same
for the change email address exactly the
same and for the reset password also
so what I propose you to do is to try to
stillies a little bit the confirm signup
email the invit user and we will see how
it looks like to actually display a nice
email to send to our users
as a mailbox I'm going to use yuckmail
it's a fake mailbox that helped me to
catch some emails these emails actually
are deleted every day every 24 hours so
this fake mailbox will help me to
subscribe to a fake user
so on the confirm sign up here we can
see that I have a template with a
variable confirmation URL and we've got
some help here about the variables that
you want to grab maybe sometimes you
will need a token the token Ash the city
URL so the URL of your seat or maybe why
not the user's email okay so me I
grabbed a quick template of the email
that I'm going to send as a confirm sign
up and I'm going to go down down there
in the editor
and that's really cool to get this
editor I'm going to copy paste this and
there we go so what I need to grab is
this confirmation URL just here
so I need to confirm the sign up okay so
what I'm going to do I'm going to change
it with here there we go so I got my
confirmation URL here and I'm going to
remove this and there we go so now when
a user is going to subscribe
okay it will receive this confirm sign
up all right but right now I don't want
to use the application so I'm going to
use exactly the same here but for the
invit because with here with my users
table I will be able to invit myself
through fake menu it will be faster so
I'm going to get back to templates here
and I'm going to go to invit user and
I'm going to copy paste the exact code
so I'm going to change
and I'm going to put you have been
invited exactly like up there thank you
to confirm
okay I'm going to change this text a
little bit because I have to be clear on
what is this invitation
you have been invited to create an
account so I'm going to change this an
account and an account on and here I can
put the URL
so actually I'm going just to grab the
same text and be safe of course about
the text so here is not confirm your
sign up
but here it's going to be this there we
go and on my button I'm going to get on
the button text it's not going to be
confirm sign up so sorry about that I'm
going to put it like this there we go
I'm going to say create an account there
we go and after on the text is best
regard if you do not initiate this sign
up please disregard this email I can
remove it okay there we go so I got my
email there and I can remove the
previous template because I want to have
only one template so as you see you just
have to write some HTML here and to
insert your configuration URL variable
and what I did me I put some CSS because
I want to have something nice
okay
um you have been invited to and here I
can put code with Geon okay there we go
so I'm going to get down I'm going to
click on Save okay all right
successfully updated so I'm going to get
back to users and I'm going to invite a
fake mail address so it's going to be
fake emails super bass at Yahoo mail.com
so I'm going to save this fakey made
super bass at yapmade.com there we go
and here we see waiting for verification
so I'm going to go on my email I'm going
to put my fake email at this fake email
superbase at shopmail.com I'm going to
click on this and there we go I got my
email with the design you have been
invited you have been invited to create
an account on blah blah blah so
localhost 3000 of course this is wrong
we should later change the url of course
create an account best regards okay so
basically if I click here what's going
to happen
and there we go it worked my fake email
super bass at Yahoo mail.com has been
recorded as a user
I'm going to get back to my template so
what we did is just the invite user but
we could do the same for the magic link
for the change email address for the
reset password the confirm sign up and
there we go if you are looking for email
templates you can either ask Chad GPT to
write one for you in HTML and CSS or you
can browse online and find the design
that you want
when a user is signing up to your
front-end application or if he envites a
user to join it for instance
well there is a redirection that is
triggered from the button in the email
and actually you have to deal with the
URL confirmation this variable that we
can find in the email template
we saw previously that we can inject
this variable inside the email templates
of different cases
however this URL has to be changed once
you are in production
because for now what we've got
we've got this site URL here which is my
localhost 3000 and you understood that
in production localhost 3000 does not
exist you need a website
so configure the URL of your site this
is used for password reset email and
other links
well this URL configuration side is very
important for super Basin especially for
you when you are going to deliver your
application for the clients in
production
so what you need to do is when you
deliver your application and you want to
redirect immediately from the web
you have to change this website URL so I
give you an example for instance me I
will have a website one day very soon
call codewydion.com and I'm gonna use
this instance of Super Bass to trigger
this redirection on password reset or on
confirmation signup I will have to
change this website URL to change
actually the variable inside the email
template down here
all right that is the first case of the
URL configuration
another case is the redirect urls
well sometimes you need to redirect
some URLs on post authentication for
instance as we see down there so
basically you can click here and add a
domain to redirect on authentication
services so this concern the redirect
URLs pattern however for most of you
here you would need just to change the
site URL to the production URL
it is time for us to look at the core
feature of Super Bass which is actually
to read insert delete or update elements
inside our table okay so right now on
I'm on my Super Bass instance and I
currently have one table called holders
and holders is composed by an idea
created at client ID price address ZIP
code city
etc
so what I would like to have is a set of
fake holders to start
so what I'm gonna do I'm going to go to
my SQL editor and I already prepared a
fake script to insert fake orders inside
my table we will insert all these fake
orders inside the table orders and later
what we're gonna do we are going to use
the SDK of Super Bass to fetch all those
orders here and what we will do also is
to do some operations on on them so we
are going to read them for sure then we
will try to insert a new order then we
will delete some orders so let's go on
my SQL editor right now I have created a
new query and I'm going to rename it
it's going to be insert 10 20 sorry fake
holders okay so I'm going to rename the
query this way and there we go and here
I'm just going to copy paste a list of
fake orders that I have created based on
my model so my table orders is composed
by colon address column zip code city
name ID client ID and Creator and there
we go success no rule returns it means
that my query didn't fail and it worked
I'm supposed to get right now all the
orders in my table orders I'm going to
go to it and there we go I got fake
orders we are missing the price for now
sorry it's a mistake but we will be able
maybe later to change it now now I got
all those fake holders what I'm gonna do
and remember on my view GS app right now
I got the SDK installed and I have my
session I'm logged in so what I'm gonna
do first I'm going to check on my
database and we never know I'm going to
check on my database if I got the row
level security okay so I got enabled row
level security okay and what about the
policies of it so I'm going to get back
to the table orders here I'm going to
click up there and we see that I got one
active role never security so we can see
that we enable the insert for
authenticated user only however I want
to grab them click on new policy I'm
going to click on get started and here
we are so enable read access to everyone
it's not exactly what I want what I want
is to select only if you are
authenticated later we will work maybe
on adding a colon with the user ID to
know who created the current order and
to manage only the current user to grab
his orders not the orders of somebody
else so I'm going to click on review I'm
going to click on Save policy so to
authenticated only role and I'm going to
save that and there we go so now we see
that we can select the orders for
authenticated all right so now what I'm
going to do I'm going to click on API
docs down there and here what we've got
is that here every time we are going to
create a new table we will have all the
code generated by the SDK for my tables
so here I got clients of course but here
I got orders also so I'm interested in
holders and here we see that we got some
code that we can copy paste directly
inside our application to get our orders
okay so here I'm not interested on
getting only one key what I would like
to have is to have all the orders okay
so let's say that I'm going to grab this
I'm going to copy this there we go again
if I would be logged in as a user to
grab my orders what I would do as a
super admin I would tell in the policies
to be able to grab only my orders okay
back in my application what I can do is
to import Super Bass okay coming from
Super Bass there we go okay so it's my
Super Bass instance which is here with
my create client and what I'm going to
do at first is to create a function okay
so it's going to be fetch orders which
will be of course an asynchronous
function in here I'm going to create a
try catch function and inside I'm going
to catch the arrow so I'm going to
console log my arrow and if there is
orders I want to console log them so I'm
going to console log my orders there we
go what I'm going to do here I'm on vgs
but it's going to work also on react
next zverdevel kit whatever I'm going to
launch this function here and let's go
so here it's not an asynchronous
component or whatever we don't care for
the moment we just want to look at our
orders and look at this there we go I
got all the fake orders I had before
without the price and as we see here
we've got all the data we asked so as
you see here just this piece of code and
using the SDK of Super Bass is helping
me to grab actually a table and to
select by using select here from holders
to grab all the orders that I wanted
okay so let's say now I want to grab
only for instance I want to grab only
the name okay and the ID instead of
putting the store I'm going to put the
ID and let's say that I would like to
have the name okay
so let's get back let's uh let's look at
it and look at this we are selecting
only the ID and the name which is really
really cool because sometimes we don't
want to grab all the data we would like
to be fast and just to have some
elements of the orders so here I'm just
selecting the ID or the name for the
foreign table I will do another video
about it to explain deeper how we can
grab some data from another table based
on a specific column okay so also what I
can do which is really cool is that I
can work with the pagination with range
so here I'm just going to grab this and
I'm going to get back and instead of
having the ID and the name I'm going to
grab all the orders I'm going to take
range here which is a value that I could
change for instance with here pagination
and because I'm on ugs I'm going to put
ref here okay so I would need to import
ref from view in my case there we go so
here I got pagination let's say I'm
going to put pagination here so
pagination dot value there we go and
when I get back and I update what's
going to happen is that I got from 0 to
9. imagine later I want to do an
infinite scroll on all the orders what I
would do is that at first I would grab
the 10 orders I would scroll down and
what I would do is to store those orders
into an array and then with the
pagination I would just increase this
number to fetch the new orders coming
from 10 to 19 for example what about
filtering so here you get a lot of
examples on how to filter okay on how to
filter your orders
so let's say that right now let's look
at it
and here I got Michael Michael Johnson
okay so let's say that I'm going to grab
this name Michael Johnson here okay and
let's say that I would like to have the
order uh of Michael Johnson so right now
I only get one but what I would do is
coming back here and using a point equal
so I'm going to go here and here the
colon will be name because on holders I
got a column name and let's say that I'm
going to put Michael Johnson as a result
I would like to have only the orders of
Michael Johnson for any reason so I'm
gonna get back here I'm going to update
and look at this I got the order of
Michael Johnson so I used dot equal to
do it all right I could use also greater
than so greater than would be for
instance if I would have a number
because right now I don't get any price
in my in my order what I would do is
actually to put the current price
greater than and I would put the number
and there's a lot of other option less
than greater than or equal to less than
or equal to case sensitive so here it
would be very nice to try another
comparator would be is here we could see
that we want to match the columns in
order that will be none
so actually I would have all of them
because right now it's a problem you
could use in to do some comparison on a
colon with another with array values so
here you would put an array and here you
would do some comparison etc etc so you
can find this in API docs filtering here
and you get a lot of options to deal
with uh some filtering on some columns
all right I got a button here insert
fake holder I'm not going to put a full
form you can do it it's really easy and
when I'm going to click on it I'm going
to insert a new order so I'm going to
pass to 20 records down there okay so
I'm going to insert a new order so what
I need to do here is to grab the
function to insert a new order so I'm
going to get back here and instead of
having all of this I'm going to use
exactly the same so here I'm going to
copy paste this function here and I'm
I'm going to not trigger fetch holder
here but to trigger it on my button so
down there I'm going to type on click
insert order so right now I don't get
this function what I need to do is to
create this function so let's change it
up there insert order okay so when I'm
going to click on insert although it's
going to insert another however what I
need to do is to write this function so
I'm going to get back here I'm going to
insert this one and here I got to insert
actually a fake order so I'm not obliged
to put an array here it here they put an
array because maybe sometimes you would
like to insert several elements but I'm
just going to put my order here so let
me write a fake holder based actually on
the model of my database all right so I
created a new order but this time there
is no idea no created at why it's really
simple to understand remember our table
order
actually generate the ID and generate at
the same time do creator that okay so I
can't push any ID that I would invent by
myself here because it will not match to
what we created on the table orders
so I got this order with address ZIP
code etc etc I can't even put a price so
I'm going to put 12 for instance
and when I'm gonna click on this insert
order it will push this into my database
so what I want to do I want to say if
there is data
I want to console log the data okay so
let's look at what is going to give to
do this
Michael is passed with a 201 there we go
and if I get back to my orders there we
go we've got 20 records so it means that
somewhere here and at the end of course
I got my order with the 12 into the
price
and it's about Emily Williams so I'm
going to show it here there we go so now
let's grab again the orders of Emily
Williams
so I'm creating a new function called
Fetch orders from emini Williams I'm
going to get down this way so I'm going
just to show it this way and instead of
having this insert that we have here I'm
going to put select all the orders
and I'm going to use the client ID
because here I can just
identify Emily Williams with it with our
client ID so I'm going to grab this one
here I'm going to console log this and
there we go so here it's going to be
holders and I'm going to console log the
holders and I'm going to fetch the
orders from Emily Williams
back in my application I update and look
at this I got the two orders of Emily
Williams once with 12 as a price and
once with null another thing that I
could do is instead of using this I
could use the name so now I'm going to
grab the name of Evian Emily Williams
there we go and here I'm going to put
name and when I get back I got the same
results I got the order of Emily
Williams you have to be always clear
about what you want to fetch either it's
going to be the name either is going to
be the client ID all right
be safe because sometimes you may have
some error if you don't match the right
client ID or the name okay so right now
I got the two MINI Williams matching
with the same client ID but in the two
case I'm supposed to have two orders if
you would have three and two in one it
would mean that either the client ID
would be false either your name would be
false also okay so this time we want to
update an order of
um Emily Williams and if I look at my
list down there we see that here Emily
Williams has a price null on a specific
element ID which is this one so what I'm
gonna do I'm going to use a function and
here it's not going to be insert in
order this function will be actually
um const update
um Emily Williams order okay so this is
a very bad practice that I'm showing
here to you but it's just into the
context so I'm going to do always the
same so it's going to be a try catch and
here it's not going to be insert order
but it's going to be updated with
Williams order so I'm going to get back
down there update Emily Williams order
okay for this example I'm going to get
back to the documentation and I'm going
to grab this code which is update here
okay what I want to do here is to Target
a specific order so here I'm going to
type here that I'm looking for a holder
with a specific ID and remember it's
this specific ID down there with the
price turn so I'm going to grab this ID
and I'm going to put it here and what I
want to update is the price and let's
say that here I'm going to put a 200
okay so I'm going to console log the
arrow if I get an arrow and I'm going to
console log the data if there is data
like always so console log data there we
go so I'm going to update the order of
Emily Williams with this ID and change
its price but the thing here is that I
didn't add on row level security Depot
the policy to update my orders so I'm
going to click here on get started and
I'm going to put here for update using
auth.gwt all right let's try again if I
click on update Emily's holder there's
nothing happening but if I update my
table and I look at the price there we
go it worked we've got the price at 200
down there and if I'm checking to my
orders there we go I got 200 here on the
price of my table
okay now let's delete this order really
easy to do like always we go here and
we've got a delete row delete matching
row we're gonna grab this and I'm going
to do exactly the same all right I got a
function called delete Emily William
order
inside I got the equivalent to the ID of
the order that I want to delete I got
delete here and when I'm gonna click
down there I will trigger the function
but before I need to add a new row level
security though so I'm going to click
here and I'm going to go down and what
I'm going to do I'm going to use this
template on authenticated again and
actually Auto uid will be
related to client ID so that's a good
example remember I got a client ID here
so let's say that we would like that
only Emily Williams will be able to
delete her own order
we'd have to match actually this client
ID with the current session I am in
right now it's not the case so what I'm
gonna do I'm just going to put true for
the example but don't do it all right I
got my rollover security so now I'm
getting back I'm updating I'm going to
click on delete Emily William order and
I'm going to update again and right now
I got only one holder because I deleted
the previous one in this course we saw
that we can read insert update or delete
element with the SDK of Super Bass
before what we have to do is to always
work on the row level security on the
authentication pardon policies and to
enable some cases if we want to insert
select update or delete our elements
from the table coming directly from our
Super Bass instance
of course with Super Bass we can
subscribe to the changes of a table here
I got a table order with 20 fake orders
okay so what I can do I can click here
an API quick start or I can go down here
on API docs but if I click here I got a
quick access to the API documentation
related to Super Bass
so I got all the code related to the SDK
and when we go down we see here that we
get subscribe to changes and here we got
the code that we can import into our
application
so right now in my app it's totally
empty I don't get the orders so what I'm
going to do I'm going to get back here
and I'm going to create a new function
called Fetch orders okay so here it will
be an asynchronous function all right
what I want to do before triggering this
fetch order I want to create an
interface because I'm on typescript
which will be an interface order in this
interface I will have the model of my
table so here it's going to be a Name ID
I created that etc etc and down there I
want to create a const orders here is
going to be a reference and this will be
an array so I'm waiting for an array
what I want to do also is to specify
here is going to be of type order here
we go so now we are going to store our
orders here what I can do is to write my
function fetch order so it's going to be
really simple I'm going to fetch from
Super Bass my orders and I'm going to
apply the orders to this variable here
then I want to trigger this fetch holder
at the end of my code and when I get
back here we go we've got all the orders
okay so now I'm going to put the order
this way and here I'm going to put the
Super Bass instance here so I'm going to
get back here and here we go so what I'm
going to do I'm going to change data
here and it will appear immediately here
but before I need to implement my code
to subscribe to actually to subscribe to
the table orders so the first thing I
need to do is to create a cons channel
here and I'm going to call Super Bass
okay and then I'm going to call the
function channel so here it's going to
be my new channel for others let's say
okay you can give the name you want and
here we go so here we are creating a
channel
so I'm going to put some space here to
be more clear here we are then I'm going
to type on and here I will take three
arguments the first one it's an argument
that is totally normal which is postgres
changes here we are then I'm going to
specify okay the event that I want so
here at the event and I want is to have
all the order back okay here you can put
the specific key that you want the
schema is going to be public
okay and here I'm going to specify the
table which will be orders okay so right
now it's on red because the last
argument will be a callback a function
and this is where I'm going to catch my
event so I'm going to console log my
event here we are last thing if you want
to put a filter you can put it here by
typing here buddy is equal and here you
can type your filter so you got equal
you get LTE
etc etc me I don't want that I want to
get back the changes here okay so here
we are at the end what we need to put of
course is dot subscribe which is a
function
so now when we gonna have changes what's
gonna happen is that we are going to
console log the changes here but before
we have to enable this real time so what
we're going to do we are going to click
here on database and we're going to go
here on replication okay on replication
I got super bass real time on insert
update delete truncate but here as we
see we've got zero table so we need to
say hey this table
is enabled for Super Bass real-time so
I'm going to click on zero table and
here we've got orders orders by client
and here we got client so here I'm going
to check on here here we go holders is
enabled for real time back into my
application we see that here Ava Wilson
is living on in Chicago on the
60606 ZIP code I'm going to change our
ZIP code and down there in the console
we are supposed to get an event console
log so I'm going to put 0
and look at this we've got the answer
from our subscribe and we've got a lot
of data here we've got the commit
timestamp we've got an update we've got
the hold data and we've got the new data
and we can see that the ZIP code is now
zero so now I have to update in my array
of orders okay this uh actually this new
data for Ava Wilson
back in my code I'm going to District
structure my event so it's going to be
const here it's going to be my event and
here it's going to be new however I
don't want to use new I want to type new
holder because here in this scope it's
an order and what I'm going to do I'm
going to apply to orders value uh nodes
dot value
dot map and here I'm going to check the
holder okay so what I'm going to do here
exactly I want to check if it's the
right idea that I want to change inside
my array so I'm going to type if order
dot ID is equal to newholder dot ID here
we are what we want to do here is to
return an object that will merge at
first the older but the new data so new
data here the New Order this way okay
and at the end of course we want to
return also the other orders alright so
here we are supposed to merge the old
data with the new data inside our orders
array locally back in my application Ava
Wilson is on the bottom and our function
will help us to not move those elements
I got Jack Jackson Thompson here at the
top and I'm going to change Jackson
Thompson here and it's supposed to
change Jackson Thompson on my app in
real time so what I'm going to do I'm
going to put code Whiskey on okay as a
value I'm going to type enter and look
at this
here we are it changed my value for code
with Geon so it's really really useful
what I'm going to do I'm going to change
also the price and this time it's going
to be 100 look at this and here we are
for Madison Perez we've got a 100 so
here in the database it's moving from
the top to the bottom but not in my
application in real time we succeed to
change the order's value and it's
applying to my array the new value
so why would you need to subscribe to
events well for different kind of
application here we are on a CRM so
we've got clients here a list of orders
but you could do that for a chat of
course because in a chat you would like
that people get the new messages in real
time so you would subscribe into your
application with the method channel on
And subscribe you would subscribe to the
list of latest messages coming from your
database
as you see it's really fast to set up
it's really easy to use of course if you
want a filter you would need to add the
filters and check out the API docs for
it but here in some minutes we succeed
to subscribe to a channel and we succeed
to update our value locally
how to make relation between tables in
Super Bass let's get an example in the
previous lessons I have created a table
orders and a table client let's start
over for this example I have here a SQL
query
that will actually create a table orders
with a model ID client ID
etc etc
I'm enabling the rule over security and
I got a table client with an ID
after I'm inserting in my clients the
email it will create an ID also and in
my table orders okay I'm going to
generate okay I'm going to generate a
fakeholder and I'm going to inject
from clients that is related to the
email of Daniel Garcia which is up there
so I'm going to click on run
and here we are so I'm going to get back
to my tables and now I'm going to have
two tables a table client with an ID
and I'm going to have a table orders
with an order
and in here I'm going to have here
exactly the client ID of the email
Danielle Garcia so the client ID of an
order
is actually the ID of a client
so now what I can do is to make a
relation between them in database here
I'm going to click on my table orders
I'm going to click here on the pen
and I'm going to add a foreign key
relation so I'm on orders and when I
click here I want to make a reference to
another table and this table here you
understood it will be clients
and of course I want to make a relation
with the ID from clients so I'm going to
click on Save and here we are we have a
relation now between every holder which
the client ID will be related to the
client's ID now I know that I got this
relation so to confirm that I can go on
the table orders
and here we see that there is a little
link here which means that there is a
relation on this colon to another colon
now I'm going to go on API docs on the
table orders and I'm going to look for
foreign key okay and down there we see
that with the SDK I have a solution to
fetch actually my orders with another
table so here you understood it's going
to be
clients
and between parentheses I'm going to put
what I'm going to put the foreign key
and in order the foreign key
it's client ID back in my app I have a
function fetch order
with a star here and what I want to do
I'm going to put here at the line
clients so the foreign tables and in
clients I'm going to put a star because
I want to have the full client of course
before I need to check if my rollover
security policies are made here it's not
the case so I'm going to add a new
policy let's say that I'm going to apply
this enable read access on clients and
I'm going to do exactly the same on
orders and here we are I got my order
down here and if I click on it
look at this
I got client ID but I also got the data
from the client so what we did here we
created a relation we used the client ID
of an order
to make a relation to another table
which is client ID
of course you can make as much relation
as you want until the moment it doesn't
imply that the colon have constraints
that are not related for example primary
Keys is nullable etc etc you gotta be
sure that your colons can fetch together
here I got a colon client so if I click
here I got some elements and I can also
here if I want make a relation okay
between the client's email and order so
here I'm going to click on select a
tables reference to and here is going to
be orders and when I click down here I
can check that
the orders email will be fetched in
relation to the client's email so I'm
going to click on Save and here we see
that we got the relation already done
and here we are I got a relation between
those two of course if you want to
delete those relation you can do the
opposite
Super Bass is built around postgres and
in postgres you can create what we call
functions functions can be triggered on
insert update delete and other steps of
your application if you don't know what
our functions in postgres I just typed
it in Google let's look at the
definition together
a postgresql function or stored
procedure is a set of SQL and procedural
commands so like SQL scripts that we get
in Super Bass
such as declaration assignments Loop
flow of control Etc stored in the
database server and can be involved
using the SQL interface
so here in postgres or Super Bass we can
create our function and if we want to
have some example we can click here on
the SQL editor and remember on the SQL
editor we can write scripts but we also
got custom scripts already written by
the Super Bass team but at first what I
want to do I want to get back to my
table editor and remember I've built
this app that is fetching the orders
from my table here orders so what I want
to do I want to go back to my table
orders and here I would like to
increment a field however there is no
field that I would like really to
increment so I'm going to add one column
here by clicking here and here we are
and what I'm going to do I'm going to
create a column called views
and it's going to be number of views of
my order it doesn't make really sense
here but it's just to give you an
example
the data type it's going to be an
integer 2. okay
and the default value would be zero
okay we don't Hello Nila ball I'm going
to click on Save and here it's going to
add to every column actually of my
orders here the views so here we don't
get the zero I don't know why maybe I
went too fast but anyway for fetch I'm
going to look at my order and here we
are we see down there that we get the
views so we would like to increment
discount every time we fetch actually
the order we can do that with functions
there are two ways to create function in
Super Bass the first one is to go to the
SQL editor and to write a script like I
have here either you can check to take
one here the second way is to go to
database and here you've got functions
on Alpha so when you click on functions
on Alpha here I already created a
function but I'm going to click on
create new function here I can create my
function so let's say that I'm going to
recreate the one I have it's increment
and it's going to be on public and here
we return void but later we will need to
return trigger if we want to pass the
trigger I can add my new argument and
down there I can copy paste the part on
PNP gsql the language to write my
function okay so down there you would
have your function let's say that as an
argument I would have my order ID which
will be an integer uh no not an integer
two but it would be a uuid here we are
and down there I would copy paste the
function that I want and here we are you
have advanced settings to change the
behavior here is going to be volatile
we've got a language we can pass some
params and we can work on the type of
security check the security invoker here
you will have your function and then you
click on confirm and it will save your
function finally you get your function
appearing here increment with the
argument where you ID with a return type
void and when you click on it you can
edit it go to the dock or delete the
function the second way is to go to your
SQL editor and to write your own
function or to select a script there so
we are going to select this increment
field value we are in the SQL editor of
course I'm going to click on here and
here we have create function increment
here so we've got some postgres here PL
SQL sorry that has been written for us
here immediately and what we would like
to do is to change a bit this function
to adapt it to our colon all right I
have a query here to actually increment
my tables view so here is the function
that I wrote and I got my update orders
and I'm setting the view plus 1 where
the row ID will be equal to ID as a
language SQL volatile there we go so I'm
going to click on run and here we are my
function is now existing if I want to
check I can go to database and to
function up here and what's appearing
here I got my function increment now I'm
getting back to my app and I have a
function increment view where I call
superbase.rpc increment the first
argument of this function is the name of
your function actually so dot RPC is the
function to call increment here and we
pass here the object with the row ID
remember this row ID we need it in our
function so if I get back to my query
here we pass the row ID which is the
uuid the row ID it's simple the ID of my
order okay so here I'm just changing
Danielle Garcia so I put here the ID
immediately of Daniel Garcia let's go
back to our app and let's check if we
pass from zero to one back in my app I'm
going to update let's look at the
network and we see down there that I
called increment here we are if I look
at the object in the console I got view
0 so I'm going to update again and let's
look there and here we are we got views
one here of course we don't count the
view that we just passed so if we get
back actually here we are we see that we
got two views for uh Daniel Garcia okay
so that's how we can call functions
immediately from our app in Super Bass
we create our function first then we
look at the rollover security uh
policies if we got something to change
to allow the the client to update or
insert and finally we call it by using
superbase.rpc the name of the function
and we can pass as many arguments as we
want
previously we created a function
together to increment our views inside
our table in Super Bass and per
extension with postgres
but we can call this function with what
we call triggers
if you want to know where are your
triggers inside Super Bass you can go
here on the left on database and when
you click on it you got a list up there
so I'm going to zoom a bit and here we
got triggers and when you click on
triggers here we are you got a list of
triggers here and you get the trigger
under every schema okay you get schema
real time schema PG sodium schema
storage and here we got the name of our
triggers and the table where they act so
here we get subscription for THX filter
we see that the function that we call is
subscription check filters and it's
triggered on certain events here it's
before insert before update so we
understand that triggers are calling
function at a certain time when there is
a special event and here we see that we
get these events before insert before
update for those who don't know postgres
let's look at the definition of triggers
postgresql triggers a database callback
functions which are automatically
performed invoked when a specified
database event occurs
so we can see here that our functional
triggers are actually linked to a
specific database a trigger that is
marked for each row is called once for
every row that the operation modify so
when we get back here we see that we've
got a function tier check filters on the
table subscription the function that is
called is subscription check filters and
here we got the events before insert
before update okay at first what we can
do is to click up here to create a new
trigger and we can see here we got the
name of a new trigger okay so here
please use snake Case by default and
here you can check the table if you want
to check a specific table so here we've
got session health we got user Hoth and
we've got up here orders the table that
we created before in this course here
are the list of the events okay we've
got insert update delete okay these are
the events you want to trigger your
trigger and the function and here you
get the trigger type so when you click
on it it's before or after as you see
here okay before the event or after the
event
for the orientation of the statement we
can say that it fire wants for each
processed rule most of the time you will
select that and down here you're going
to choose the function to trigger so
this is the first way to add a new
trigger if you don't want to use the SQL
editor you can go here and click to add
a new trigger and down here you would
select the function that you would have
created previously if you want to know
how to create a function please refer to
the listen on functions
okay I'm going to write a SQL query to
create a table to create a function to
add every time somebody is going to
authentify to my Super Bass instance a
row in this table users be safe it's not
going to be about the auth.user stable
is going to be about the users table and
then I'm going to create a trigger
immediately so I'm going to click here
on new query and what I'm going to do
I'm going to type create table users
okay right now I don't got any table so
here it's going to be good it's going to
be with an ID with uuid references here
auth.users okay not null and it's going
to be primary key here we are so I'm
going to zoom a little bit for you here
we are then it's going to have an email
and I'm going to store the email text
here okay so I'm going to go down here
and what I'm going to do I'm going to
create also a function so I'm going to
type create or replace because maybe
we're going to run the query several
time if we make mistakes
okay function and here is going to be
public
dot handle a new user here we are there
we go and then we are going to return
here returns a trigger it's really
important at this step to return the
trigger because we fix the trigger on
this function okay you have to return
the trigger so here is going as double
dollar here we are and we are going to
type begin and end and between those two
we are going to pass our function and we
want to say insert
into public dot users so here the table
that we've got up there
we want to insert an ID and animate and
where it's going to come from where it's
going to come from the new user that is
going to uh actually log in or subscribe
to my application so basically here
we've got new that is available in my
scope so what I can do is to say values
here and it's going to be new ID and
then I'm going to pass new DOT email
okay so here I'm going to return new
here we are and after I'm going to show
you where it comes from exactly
here we are so at the end I'm going to
type here language and here is going to
be PLP gsql and it's going to be of type
security definer here we are and here we
are we've got our function here that is
going to work
okay down here I'm going to create a
trigger so I'm going to type create
trigger and here on new user okay and
here it's going to be after insert
and it's going to be on auth.users here
we are and down there what I want to
write here is that for each row I want
to do what I want to execute procedure
okay and here it's going to be what I
think you understood is going to be
public handle new user and here we are
it's supposed to be good so now I'm
going to go on my database I'm going to
go on functions
and here on function we see that we've
got handle new user which is written
type trigger okay and if I go on my
triggers here down here I'm going to
unzoom here we are we can see that we've
got a new user which is my trigger that
is going to call what it's going to call
actually we don't see it here but it's
going to call my function okay let's get
back to our tables and here we've got a
table that has been created there is no
row level security enabled so maybe I
would I want to do it so I'm going to
type enable row level security we've got
our table with ID and email and what
we're going to do we are going to go to
authentication add a new user and see if
our trigger is going to be actually
calling the function and had the new
user so I'm going to click here on
authentication here we are so I'm going
to take this fake user it's going to be
this one and I'm going to put a new
number click on invit user
okay the invit has been sent and now if
I go to my table users
here we are we see that we've got our
function that has been triggered all
right so what we did here we created in
our script a table users then we created
a function and this function can be
found here in functions Alpha here and
all new user and if I click here exactly
we've got the code that I wrote between
begin and hand just here with the public
etc etc then I created a trigger called
our new user that is triggered after
insert and this trigger is triggered
every time there is a new user on the
table Hoth so if I get back to my table
I got my own table user public dot user
which is here we see the schema and what
happened is that I added a new user
through the authentication system
I invited a new user so if I click here
and I look at the schema down here which
is half
I get a list of tables related to the
schema half and down there I get users
and we can see that in users I got my
new user here so when I have a new user
it's new DOT email that I catched inside
my function
and with this new email that I catch
inside my function I said add it to the
public dot user table
Super Bass is built around postgres and
of course postgres is using schemas so
what are schemas well actually a schema
it's a name container for database
objects such as tables views sequences
indexes functions schemas are a way to
organize the separations and to organize
your database objects a schema is
essentially a namespace that contains
one or more objects by default there is
a schema called public so here when I go
back to my table we can see up here that
we can select the current schema we are
on depending the tables so when I click
here I can select for instance half and
we see that I access new table so we
understand that half and public are two
different schema containing their own
tables so by default this schema is the
G4 schema public okay and all objects
created without specifying a schema will
end up in public by default so why do we
need such a thing why do we need schemas
well I told you first it's for the
organization you can separate some parts
of your application directly through
those schemas of course schemas are used
to manage permission let's say that some
part of your application you will need
to be available only for admins you will
do some schema like admin or you would
have the public that would be for public
etc etc you can create as much schema as
you want and you can determine actually
to who you want to build this schema for
schemas are also amazing to avoid naming
conflicts here on public I got a table
user alright with two columns but if I
go on half I also got a table user
depending on another source of data so I
have dot users but I got also public dot
users so here we avoid the match between
two table that got the same name but
don't get the same columns the same
model schemas are also amazing to
facilitate the multi-tenancy of your
application so what does it mean well
let's imagine that you got multiple
clients and you want the customer to
share data each client can have their
own schema those multiple clients it
helps them to keep the data separated
and organized basically a schema
provides some help to separate the
concerns of your table to manage and
secure your database particularly when
the size is going to grow up and the
complexity is going to make trouble to
your developers to understand where are
the data exactly and to not mix the
database names okay so let's get back to
the SQL editor and we are going to
create our first schema so here I got a
create schema sales this will create
those schema says so I'm going to create
a table and here it's going to be the
name of the schema so sales that
customers all right and inside here I'm
going to have what I'm going to have a
ID type uuid and it's going to be
actually no
primary key here we are then we would
have a name it would be a text okay and
an email that would be a text also here
we are so I'm going to click on run
and look success no rule return I'm
going to get back to my table and if I
go to schema suddenly I got the schema
sales okay so I'm going to click on
sales and now I got the customer with
which is actually empty right now but I
created a separated part of my
application through the schema so now I
got the public and I can have the schema
sales if I want to store customer
somewhere else in a different business
logic or different part of concern of my
application
storage in Super Bass is super easy Once
you have created your project you can go
down here to storage okay and when you
click here you arrived on the list of
the buckets the buckets it's the places
it's where you are going to store all
your documents images whatever okay so
here we are so I'm going to click on
create a new bucket and here let's say
I'm going to create a bucket for avatars
alright
so here I can only enter letters number
dots and hyphens all right so buckets
cannot be renamed once created so be
safe on the name you are going to give
if I click done there here it's going to
be a public bucket so if it's public
anybody who's got your url will be able
to fetch and see the image okay so here
for avatars it's the case Okay I want it
to be public but be safe if you want to
have a specific document that are going
to be private you will not edit this
public bucket but you will work with row
level policies after to be able for the
users to fetch the document the private
document they uploaded before
so down here I got a warning public
records are not protected users can read
objects in public bucket without any
authorization okay rollover security
policies are still required for other
operations such as objects upload and
delete so we see now that when we create
a bucket actually we have to still write
some rollover security policies to be
able to fetch the elements so I'm going
to click on create the bucket avatars
and here we are and we see up here that
we've got a label public that tells us
that here it's public it's available on
fetch okay so what I'm gonna do up here
is to upload the file however I can if I
won't create a folder or so I can reload
or etc etc so I'm going to click on
upload the file and here I got the image
the term name of the current
video that you are watching here it's
storage.png and when I click on it I got
some information here here's the
thumbnail you get the image size you get
the date you can download it get the URL
so I'm going to click on get the URL and
I'm going to enter the URL up here and
we see that there is a public inside the
inside the URL so it means that I can
fetch it and here we are we got the
image available thanks to the bucket
option that we get here download of
course if I want to delete I can click
delete it here I can also download it
immediately okay so what I'm gonna do
I'm going to delete this file for now
and now in my application I'm going to
push actually the image directly from
some kind of Avatar element that helped
me to upload the image alright here we
are I got this upload element with
terrin CSS and when I click on it I can
upload an element however I didn't work
on the rollover security yet so what I
need to do is to get back to my
application and go to my script SQL
editor I have written this SQL script
to tell that I want to enable on a
certain table the row level security
okay so here we see that the schema is
storage so let's have a look let's get
back on our table editor remember and if
I click down there I got a look for a
schema called storage and this is where
is the schema with all the tables and
all the policies related actually to the
storage so I'm going to click here on
upload and here we are look we've got
three tables we got buckets okay we've
got migration and we got objects so I'm
going to click on bucket and when I
click on bucket What's Happening Here is
that I got actually a table with Name ID
okay I with id id and name Avatar sorry
I got a created date Etc public true
Auto detection Force etc etc okay so
here is it's the bucket I created it's
the table related to the buckets that
I'm going to create in the future look
at this on objects I got an entrance
okay that is pushed here so what I got
to do is to enable the rollover Security
on storage and object so I'm going to
get back to my SQL editor and let's look
at this query that we got down there
and the table objects enable whatever
security and here I'm saying for select
operation okay I want to select only if
you are authenticated otherwise you
cannot select any element
also for insert and I have to use with
check instead of using here it's really
important for insert okay
we check
um actually I want to insert only if my
role is authenticated same for update
simple delete I'm going to run this
query and it's going to enable the raw
level security on storage.object and had
these four policies here once it's done
I can go to authentication policies
click here on schema and go down to
storage and I can look here that for
objects I got those row level security
here already entered alright so what I
can do now is to get back to my storage
here to avatars and here I got my
component so let me show you how this
component looks like it's a component
made with Tailwind if there is an image
URL I'm going to show it otherwise I
have an avatar upload button here with
the SVG that helps me to input actually
an image so up here I got my function
handle file input change here we are so
we got the file that I'm going to upload
and I'm going to use my client Super
Bass storage from Avatar and I'm going
to upload here I'm changing the name of
the file Avatar with here the date and I
just put the date this way if you want
to put something else like for instance
the email of the person authenticated or
something else you can do it here then
if there is an error I'm going to show
the error it's a basic function help
here to push on my storage so I'm going
I'm using actually the storage from the
SDK client the storage function with
from and upload to upload my file let's
get back let's open the console I'm
going to click here I'm going to click
on storage
and here we are we see that I get my
image so it's not very nice from now we
would say that we would deal with a
squared image for an avatar anyway and
here I got my image on my network I have
a 200 for the Avatar and the date and
now if I get back to my bucket I'm going
to reload
and here we are I have uploaded my
avatar okay it's as easy as this of
course you would have several bucket in
the future maybe with different folders
where you are going to push into okay
but it's as easy as this first you
create your bucket then you write your
raw level security policies then you
create your function here thanks to the
SDK of super bass in your application
you use storage from and you upload with
the name of the file then the file
itself
as a backend as a service of course
Super Bass is keeping track of all the
events through logs whatever is
happening within your application Super
Bass is creating logs if a user is
subscribing you have a look if a user is
creating a record you have a log if he's
updating a record etc etc so you can
find all the logs of Super Bass here in
the application here on logs so when you
click on it you arrive on the dashboard
here on actually
and Editor to write your query inside
your postgres instance
to get all the logs of the last 24 hours
for instance or you can get the logs of
a custom date logs can be very helpful
in many ways first with logs you can
debug your application
so everything that you're gonna do here
you're gonna find some track for
instance inside here inside the postgres
instance so as you see here I got a
track right now on what I'm doing and
whatever is happening in here so when
you will get an arrow for instance here
we've got a fatal arrow down here I can
keep track on what's happening on my
Super Bass instance so here it's helping
me to know if something goes wrong
inside the application so logs are here
to help me to know if an error happen
okay if an arrow occurred inside my
application so now I can fix the problem
I can troubleshoot my uh actually my
process my application here and through
here this list of logs that are very
consistent we can see here that almost
every second I got four or five logs I
can click and I can know what happened
here so of course in terms of security
logs are very useful because I can track
the user activity and I can see really
clear really fast if a request indicates
some kind of security breach inside my
Super Bass instance however here it's
not supposed to happen super bases super
strong as a backend as a service but we
never know we want to always get a hand
on what's Happening Here and this is why
the logs are very useful for security
another thing is that the logs help us
to work with the performance
optimization all right so actually by
when you analyze the logs you can see
which queries are taking the longest to
execute you can have some metrics on
what is taking a lot of resources on
your Super Bass instance well there's a
lot of stuff that you can do you can see
also which endpoints are the most
frequently requested and give you an
Insight on what is the feature you
created that is the most used so let's
explore a little bit the dashboard of
the logs so here we've got the postgres
instance so as I showed you here we we
have the list and up here we can see
that we got a refresh but with a
real-time notification here with 18 new
events so when I'm clicking on this look
at this I'm refreshing my logs and I got
here the locks time the request that I
got actually here on my Super Bass
instance
and I got the latest logs okay so I can
refresh I can click also on severity to
get only the error so here I'm going to
just save this and let's have a look and
what's going to happen here I'm going to
have only the arrows okay so if I'm
clicking again and I put no error of
course I will have no Euro and if I want
to have all the logs I can click on log
this way all right here if I'm clicking
on chart here I can display or not the
chart that I got on the top all right so
here I'm just going to remove this I'm
going to save again and start again for
you to understand here we are and as you
see I can hide the hide and show the the
chart by clicking on this button I have
the option to download the log so I'm
going to save the logs and I'm going to
open them and I have them as a CSV file
all right so through this CSV file we
can see here that I got all the logs of
my Super Bass instance okay so here when
I go here on query I can query actually
my super bass or postgres instance to
get okay the latest logs that I want
okay I can click over here on Saved
queries so let's say that I want to
write some queries that I want to launch
really often I can save them here I got
the recent queries here and if I don't
know how to write queries for this log
Explorer I got templates that are here
so it's really nice from the team of
Super Bass to think about people who
don't know how to write queries here you
got some templates that you can use I
get also the API Edge Network that
helped me to retrieve all the calls made
on my instance through the API Edge okay
on the host log it's different here if I
want to change actually let's say that I
want to have the last three days logs
what I need to do here is to upgrade my
plan here okay for the log retention I
need to pass to a paying plan so I need
to upgrade my plan for the storage here
I'm going to do exactly the same it's
exactly the same I will need to pay to
get logs for the storage also because
there is still the duration of three
months log retention and for the real
time you understood it's exactly the
same here it's a paying feature but is
the most important to remember it's that
every time you want to debug Super Bass
you can go to your instance and go to
logs down there and click on your
postgres instance and in here you will
see all the requests if they succeed or
not and you will be able to debug just
from here so I didn't show you but down
here you get some metadata that you can
also use which is very useful if you
want to know what was wrong in your
request what happened and why it failed
one of the advantage of postgres is that
it's extensible it means that the user
can add additional functionalities to
progress through what we call extensions
and of course with Super Bass we've got
access to extensions
so when you are on your instance on the
left you go to database then you go here
to extensions and by default you got a
lot of extensions that are already
enabled so here you see you get a check
and when you click you can turn on or
turn off your extension but if you go
down there is a bigger list of extension
that you can add
so what kind of extension would you need
well for instance here you get the
extension PG underscore net and this PG
underscore net here we've got a
description it's an asynchronous HTTP
extension that helps you to actually
trigger the extension to make
asynchronous HTTP call extensions in
postgres are actually software modules
that had extra feature to progress they
are developed by the postgres community
and most of the time when you want to do
stuff inside your functions you may want
first to enable an extension to do it
because by default here you don't get
the asynchronous HTTP call inside
postgres you gotta had this extension PG
net that will help you later to use it
inside a function that you are going to
declare Super Bass is built on top of
postgres it is supporting postgres so it
means that actually you can use
everything that comes from postgres so
if you find an extension available on
postgres there's a lot of chances that
it's already inside your super base
dashboard if you are looking for more
information about postgres extensions
you can go on the official documentation
of Super Bass and here we've got some
explanation so I already told you that
it's in the database on the dashboard
but down here you got a list of the
extensions that are available and If you
look here for the extension you can type
HTTP here we've got an example with the
HTTP client for postgresql allows web
page retrieval inside the database so
what I propose you to do now is to give
an example on how to use an extension
alright so right now I'm on my Super
Bass dashboard and here we see that I
don't get the HTTP extension yet so I'm
going to look on the list and we can see
here that I got the extension just here
on top of me so I'm going to click on
switch on the switch and here I'm going
to enable the extension for the schema
extension so I'm going to click on
enable extension
and here we are so we've got the HTTP on
now we can create a function that is
going to make an HTTP call I'm on MySQL
editor and I have created this function
let's look at it a little bit I got a
create or replace function get API data
that is going to return to me a Json
okay and I got a URL that I'm going to
call for an example.com API data and I'm
supposed to gather a Json from this API
but I would like my function to do this
operation
so I have enabled before the HTTP module
and I'm calling the URL here so HTTP
here it's coming from the extension that
we enabled before in the database and in
extensions so here the function is going
to process to the call through the
extension HTTP alright this is because I
have enabled the extension HTTP that I'm
able to create this function to make my
call
through the URL that I declared up there
and this is where I'm going to get the
response Json up here okay so the thing
is that here I can use my HTTP function
because it's already
enabled in the extension bar if you
would have done it
through postgres by default what we
would have done actually is to say
create the extension if not exist HTTP
here we don't need to do that because we
are in the Super Bass environment and we
don't need to declare this function
declaration creation before because we
already enabled it on the extension part
so you got to understand that through
the extension there's a lot of
possibilities that you can trigger a lot
of modules that you can find that you
can add actually to Super Bass okay I'm
just showing you today the HTTP one but
you can for instance enable graphql with
Super Bass okay you can work with the
Json web token API for postgres with PG
gwtdt which is enabled here the pgpg
crypto etc etc what you got to do is to
look for an extension that is doing the
job you are looking for that's the best
solution to do and you can look to it on
the Super Bass documentation here to see
which are the extensions that are
enabled for instance here we've got the
Geo extension that we can look through
we got the data set one etc etc but you
can also look at the postgres regular
extensions that are available through
Super Bass of course
let's talk about real time and with
Super Bass we can do real time so what
is real time
here I got an application that I have
created and I'm going to push online
okay
and in this application you will be able
to write messages and hear those
messages will be like in real time like
a chat okay so what I want to do here is
to create first a table a new table and
this table is going to be called posts
okay and on this post I would be I will
have an idea created at okay and what I
want to do I want to actually add the
model of my message so here we see that
we've got a name so I'm going to add a
name and here is going to be a text okay
and then I will have a description okay
and here it will have a text also so
here I want to say it's not going to be
nullable for both of them we want to
have some content and here we are so I'm
going to click on save all right I got
my post table but I didn't enable real
time here so what I'm going to do I'm
going to click on database here I'm
going to go on the table post which is
here and I'm going to click here you see
we've got enable real-time broadcast
changes on this table to Auto write
subscriber so I'm going to do this I'm
going to click on Save
and when it's done what I need to do is
to go on authentication on policies and
I need to add some actually some
policies to my table so I'm going to
click here on add a new policy I will
say that I will enable the read access
to everyone and I don't need anything so
here I can select the role Anon so I'm
going to click on review save policy so
everybody will be able to select the
post now I want to say that I want that
everybody can be
um actually a poster so I'm going to
click here on news template here we are
and I'm going to unzoom a little bit and
I'm going to remove here authenticated
okay I'm going to put Anon and I'm going
to click on review so now everybody on
the post table will be able to get the
messages and to insert them but before
we send our message we need to have a
look a little bit at the code so what do
I have here I have an insert here that
actually is inserting the new message
that I get up here okay and what I do
here I'm pushing the message of course
locally if we've got data in return so
that's the first thing let's see if we
can push messages into our posts table
okay let's go let's say test test I'm
going to click Send I'm going to update
and here we are we've got test here and
if we look at our database we've got a
test down here also so I'm going to
delete this row let's say that now what
I would like to do is when I put my uh
actually my message here I would like to
him to appear here so what I can do is
to create a second function called Fetch
message that we can have down there and
call it once I have sent my message
that's the first solution and the second
solution is of course to subscribe to
the table post so here with that code
with client.channel and here we are
going to subscribe to
a custom channel so here it's going to
be the name that I give it can be
anything I can say on to channel on
postgres changes I'm going to subscribe
to any event here with the um star on
the schema public and on the table post
so I'm going to console log my payload
here just to see if I got an answer
every time I'm going to push a message
here it is supposed to answer so I'm
back in my app now I'm going to say code
with geom and I'm going to type hello
there and I'm going to click on send
and look at this I got an answer from my
subscribe and I got the message down
there so if we look here we've got an
answer from the table in real time
because we enable real time before
and because we put this code a client
channel on we are listening we are
subscribing down here to the table post
that we've got here and in real time
when there is some changes here we can
see that we are notified so what I'm
doing here I'm pushing to my message
list okay the new message on the payload
so this is why I got this message here
and if I'm getting back to my
application we can see that my message
has been recorded if you want to test
this real-time functionality on my own
database
you may go to Super Bass
minusrealtime.netlyphi dot app here you
can try in real time to post messages
and maybe you will see some other people
posting messages at the same time
Edge function became really popular the
last years and with Super Bass you can
of course create those serverless
function that helps you to trigger some
operations let me give you an example
you have a front-end application and you
need to create a payment with stripe you
will need to create a an API actually
between your client and stripe to
trigger this payment intent how would
you do you would create a node.js
application that you would deploy
somewhere and it's a lot of work it's a
lot of time and you may not have that
time well the solution is to create
actually an edge function to do that but
you could also use this ad function to
do a lot of other stuff such as creating
a bot for Discord a bot for Twitter or
maybe a bot for telegram you have to
understand that this Edge functions are
serverless and they help you to deploy
really quickly a server that where you
are going to trigger some actions
alright so in my Super Bass instance I
go here on edge function and what I can
see here is that I got no Edge function
yet so I would need to create my first H
function in my Super Bass project so
back here I got my Super Bass project
and what I'm going to do here I'm going
to copy paste this Super Bass function
new hello world but before we do that I
propose you to look at the documentation
okay so H functions here are server side
type script function distributed
globally at the edge close to your user
so you can use third-party Library like
stripe but also Dino for instance and
this is what we're gonna do if you want
to have some examples you can go down
there with Super Bass yes course headers
react native flutter etc etc OG image
generation and storage CDN caching
there's a lot of stuff that you can do
with Edge function and if you are
looking for some project done with Edge
functions you can go on the Super Bass
GitHub repository and here on the
examples here on the Super Bass function
you get a lot of examples so for
instance here we see that we've got Edge
function with open AI with open graph
paper tier if you want to do some boat
or some scrapping
streams striper books which are really
useful when you want to do some payments
and telegram but but there are a lot of
other projects that you can look at us
we are going to start by creating our
own function so I'm going to copy paste
my Super Bass function new hello world
so as we can see I created a super base
folder with a subfolder called function
with the name of my new function that I
created so here when I type new after I
can put the name I want it will give the
name of the function all right so how
does it work I got an index.ts file that
is created by default and here we see
that we've got a Geno server here so
we've got some commands here and down
here we have the command if we want to
invoke our function all right so right
now this function is doing what it's
importing serve from Dino here we've got
Dino
that is exported from a Content delivery
Network all right from the official
dino.land website and we've got the
function serve and here we serve a
node.js application okay a dino is Yes
actually here so it's really simple uh
in our request okay we are supposed to
get uh the name in the request as a Json
then we create an object and we return
as a response this object so how does it
work well now we've got this function
right now our Super Bass instance
doesn't know okay what we need to do is
to deploy this function from our project
to our Super Bass instance so to do that
I'm going to get back and here we see
that we've got deploy your function so
I'm going to copy paste this I'm going
to get back to my application and right
now I am logged in on my Super Bass
instance if you are not you will have to
type Super Bass login or right and down
here it will ask you the access token so
if you don't have it you have to click
on this link to open it and here you
have to generate a new token so I'm
going to click here this name is going
to be my new token let's say okay I'm
going to click on generate a token and
here we are so here be safe I get this
token I have to copy this access token
somewhere and to keep it because it's
really really important I'm going to
copy paste and I'm going to get back and
I'm going to enter my access token here
and here we are I'm logged in on my
Super Bass instance so now what I can do
is to get back here and copy paste again
my Super Bass function deploy hello
world so I'm going to get back and I'm
going to copy paste Super Bass the
functions deploy hello world be safe
hello world here is a reference to my
folder so if you gave another name you
have to change the name here okay so I'm
going to deploy it directly from my code
editor here from my project locally to
my Super Bass instance I'm going to type
enter
and here it says building hello world
and then I got the message deployed
function hello world on the project etc
etc all right
when I get back in my Edge function I
got my Edge function here so what I can
do is just copy and paste this URL I'm
going to open it inside my browser and
why do I got this missing authorization
error of course because here I cannot
call my Super Bass function if I'm not
authorized
all right remember that you will need
the token if you keep the authorization
with GWT so you get the token down here
you would copy paste it inside your
header otherwise what you can do just to
test is to click here on the function
itself and here you get some information
about the name if you want to change
your name then you get some other
information and down here you got infos
GWT verification going to disable this
just for the example please don't do it
for the function that you use all the
time otherwise anybody could call your
function okay so I'm going to click on
Save now I'm going to call again my
endpoint here I'm going to do a post and
I'm going to post the name because
remember on our function we need to
catch the name okay and it's supposed to
return to us hello name so let's start
let's try to call the endpoint itself we
just deployed I'm going to click on send
and look at this here we are we've got
our message all right so here we see
that our server is doing some operation
for us and that's really cool let's
clean this a little bit and what we
would like to do so I'm going to keep
keep this also what I would like to do
is maybe to call my Super Bass instance
so let's give an example right now I got
this function in a word running and what
I would like to do is actually to call
my database here my tables and let's say
that I would like to get for instance
the post so I'm going to look at the
post and here we've got a lot of posts
previously of a lot of people that wrote
here a lot of messages to test the real
time so let's say that I would like to
call here on my request
my Super Bass instance and get the post
by the edge function it's totally
possible what I would do at first is to
call create client from the Super Bass
SDK that I'm calling up here from a
Content delivery Network then what I
would need to do is here to pass some
Secrets some environmental variables
what we need to do here is to create a
new file here it's going to be an of
file and I'm going to copy paste some
keys that will help me to access to the
Super Bass instance the first one is
going to be a Super Bass URL so here I'm
putting an underscore on the top of it
to don't get any error and then it's
going to be the Super Bass Service key
if I want to find those keys I can go to
Project settings API here I got my URL
and down here I need to get what we call
the service role key here it's going to
give me all the access okay so now I can
create my client when I initiate my
Super Bass function so I'm going to use
my Super Bass URL that I got in my own
file here locally in the same folder
then I got the Super Bass Service keyhub
here and I'm creating the client down
there so I go on my API docs I got my
post and let's say that I want to have I
want to read all the posts so what I'm
going to do I'm going to click here let
data post so I'm going to go down here
here we are and I'm going to actually
return so here I'm returning the data
exactly here so what I can do is instead
returning an object with data anyway and
here I can return my post okay so what
I'm going to do now is that when I am
going to request hello world it's going
to return to me the yellow with name
whatever or let's say that I'm going to
put by default Geon because I don't want
to put game all the time and then I'm
going to return all the posts from my
Super Bass instance so you understand
here that I'm using the SDK inside my
Super Bass Edge function to provide some
actions so here I'm just selecting but
let's say that later you would have an
API to do some operation some crude
operations so create read update or
delete you can use the SDK directly from
here but the thing here is that I don't
get my of file that is deployed
immediately on my function so what I
would need to do is here to push my
environmental variable to my Super Bass
instance and to do that we are going to
use the Super Bass deploy secret
function so I'm going to type Super Bass
secret set
minus minus of file and here what I need
to do is to go to the super base folder
so here it's in Super Bass function
hello world and here of course I need to
type of okay just here I need to type
off okay so I'm going to type enter and
when I type enter I got an arrow called
Super Bass link so what I want to do I
want to type Super Bass link and here I
need to enter my database password if I
look for the password what I need to do
is to go to Project settings database
and here I got a password and it's
written the password you pre you
provided when you created this project
if you get trouble you can reset the
database password I get my password so
now I can type Super Bass link and I
want to pass the password so I'm going
to type minus p and I'm going to type my
password and type enter okay now I can
come back on the command I entered
before I'm going to type enter
and here we are finished super bass
secret set so now I can deploy again so
again Super Bass function deploy in a
world
it's going to build again
and at the end here we are we've got our
hello world function working okay here
we are let's call again our function I'm
going to click on send
and here we are so I got my message from
the server and look at this I got the
list of the post that you posted on the
real-time application that I have
created before so what we did here we
created a function
that is calling our Super Bass instance
and that is providing to us some
operations that we can do
so you got to see the function like a
dino server that you can call anytime to
do some specific operation okay let's
get back on everything that we've done
since the beginning we created a
function that we deployed immediately on
our Super Bass instance
then we can request this function to do
some operation what is this H function
this H function is actually a dino
server and this Dino server can do
anything that a backend could do it can
do many operation it can be connected to
stripe it can be connected to upspot it
can be connected to many other libraries
everything that is an API actually we
can make call we can make asynchronous
operation but also we can call our Super
Bass instance and use the SDK from Super
Bass exactly like we do
in a front-end application to do some
operations so here we've got the select
from post that is returning to us the
post of the previous users okay so here
the edge functions
are playing the role of a backhand
serverless okay it's a distant backend
that you are going to call
I'm not going to show you in this lesson
how to use it locally because you would
have to work with Docker and you would
have to do some more configuration and
in the description I'm giving you the
link to work with Edge functions locally
it's a video from the Super Bass team
and it's a very good tutorial from torch
Thor is a member of the Super Bass team
but you have to think about Edge
functions like a way of creating really
fast a dino server to do some operations
for you
if you are familiar with the concept of
webbooks you get to know that with Super
Bass you can also create some web books
web books are a way for two apis to
connect together and to exchange some
data to communicate every time there is
an event and of course inside of Super
Bass you can do the same
inside of my Super Bass project what I'm
going to do I'm going to click here on
database then I'm going to click here on
webbooks okay and then what I have here
is database webbooks database webos can
be used to trigger serverless function
or send requests to an HTTP endpoint so
I'm going to click on enable webbooks
and then I can click on create webbook
but before we create the Web book I
would like to create an endpoint with an
API so what I did here is I created an
xgs 13 application okay and I got an API
endpoint here on my route and what it
does is just have two endpoints a get
endpoint where I get data in return and
data up here will have the data sent by
my Web book okay this is just an example
and this is just to show you how you can
work with an API then here down there I
get a post endpoint and when I post here
I'm updating the data up here so what I
got here as a response is a status 200
data and a message down there so what
I'm going to do I'm going to deploy this
application on Versa and I'm going to
check if it is working all right I'm on
Verso I deployed this application that I
got here it's totally dumb there's
nothing on it right now but here up here
I got an endpoint I'm going to type
slash API and look at this here we are
right now I got just an email with a
record here so what we would like to do
is to post on this endpoint from my
webbook so I'm going to get back up here
I'm going to click on create a Web book
and here I'm going to say for instance
it's going to be new user let's say new
user Web book this way here we are so
I'm going to click on here and what I'm
going to to do actually I can just pause
and go to the table public users for
instance or I can go on my auth users up
here so let's say I'm going to go on
auth users and what I'm going to do I'm
going to say that on the events insert
down here I want to do an HTTP request
so of course you can do update you can
do delete etc etc down here we see that
I can also call a Super Bass Edge
function but there are a lot of other
examples online uh to to watch if you
want to create a Super Bass Edge
function and what I'm going to do I'm
going to click on method post and here
I'm going to put my endpoint okay I got
the content type application Json here
we are okay so actually it's not going
to be a new user Web book it's going to
be let's say last user subscribe that's
what I want to catch okay I want to
catch the last user that subscribe on
this webbook okay so here I can go down
I get my HTTP request I'm going to post
and I'm going to click on create webbook
and here we are so right now I get this
Web book that is running and on insert
to a new user so I can click here on
edit hook on insert on the table half
users it's supposed to update here the
data that we will get and remember on my
endpoint I'm going to save the data in
here in this data I'm going to go on
authentication I'm going to have a new
user to my table and let's say it's
going to be Aurelia at yopmail.com
whatever I'm going to click on invit
user and here we go so now let's check
if my application on version has been
called click on API and look at this
here we are I got the whole data coming
from actually the user so here it's
really bad to do that okay because here
it's public you should never record
something like this I should only record
the email for instance so I'm going to
um actually I'm going to fix this right
away right I did an update up here when
I'm gonna get my endpoint I just want to
have the
data.record.email okay so here you get
the schema it was coming from the full
set of data that we had before we don't
want to deliver all the data here all
right it's deployed now I'm going to add
a new user aurelia12 at yopmail.com I'm
going to click on invit user and here
we've got Aurelia in the list
now I'm getting back here I'm going to
update my endpoint
and here we are we've got our last user
Aurelia on my application on versal HUB
here okay so up here we see that I got
my latest user as we saw we can create
web books to trigger some operation to
trigger some calls when we insert update
or delete any table and this is really
useful because down here we can see that
we can send HTTP request or we can call
Super Bass Edge function with different
method and we can give parameters to it
so web books are a feature that I like a
lot that I use a lot personally because
I send data to a lot of other endpoints
you can imagine a lot of stuff with that
that's really useful
in this video I'm going to show you how
to self-host a Super Bass instance so
basically what we can do we can run
super bass locally so what we will need
to do is to install first Super Bass to
run some commands and then we will be
able to launch our Super Bass instance
locally on my terminal I'm going to type
Brew install and here I'm going to type
Super Bass slash tab slash Super Bass
I'm going to type enter and it's going
to install on my machine okay it's done
nothing right now my Super Bass package
that I need so I'm fetching super bass
once it's done what I need to do is to
type superbase login
and here I need to get a token so I'm
going to open my Super Bass instance
then what I need to do is to generate a
new token and let's say it's going to be
local uh local let's say local I'm going
to generate this new token and here we
are so I got my token which is here I'm
going to copy paste get back and I'm
going to enter my token now when it's
done I'm going to create a new folder so
here it's going to be for instance my
Super Bass local project okay I'm going
to type enter then I'm going to enter
into my Super Bass local project then
I'm going to type Super Bass init I'm
going to type init and then it's done
and what I want to do I want to type
Super Bass start okay so I'm going to
type enter and here I'm supposed to get
an error okay so if you got an arrow
what you need to do is to install Docker
because here super bass start need to
have a Docker instance to run as you see
up here if you don't know Docker yet
it's a tool that helps you actually to
run containers to run instances of code
inside your machine okay so we need to
install Docker here so you can install
Docker desktop or you can go more down
and find a download link Docker is used
by many companies it's a very useful
tool if you want to know more about
Docker I'll let you look online
once you've installed Docker you're
supposed to have something like this
back into the project I'm going to type
again Super Bass then start I'm going to
type enter and here it's going to pull
the images and it's going to run all the
containers that I need to make my
instance running so I should wait a
little bit because sometimes you can
then take time to pull everything and to
complete the whole project but once it's
done we will get a message that our
instance will be running all the time
every time there will be Docker that
will run okay so it's supposed to be
done we've got several URL here the
graphql URL the API the DB URL which is
our postgres instance so for those who
really look at where is the postgres
instance you get it here there is also
the studio URL so the studio it's simply
the dashboard made with nextgs and
Tailwind that gives you access to the
Super Bass instance okay you got your
Anon key you got your service roll key
you got everything in here so I'm going
to open my studio and look at this here
we are so we've got our local Super Bass
instance running so I'm going to show
you the URL here so it's running on my
localhost and I can use the default
project that I got here all right so I'm
running super bass locally in this
machine I got my table I got my SQL
editor I got my database with all the
main features that we've got usually the
authentication but it means some
specification here some features that we
have it's going to come up with time but
basically here I can run super bass
locally with the basic feature that we
have on the cloud on the
app.superbase.com free instance or a pro
instance that you get so when I go on
Docker here we can see that I got my
Super Bass local project which is
running with several different okay
containers so the main question now is
how to migrate from local here to a
Super Bass instance if you want to move
all your work from here somewhere else
you can go to the guide of superbass.com
okay the guide is on the URL
superbass.com docs guide CLI local
development and here you got more
information why I'm not doing a video
about this because there are already
this guide so here it's everything that
we've done super Bassy needs to play
base start etc etc and down there you
get already a video about database
migration okay so here you can look at
this video if you want to migrate your
database it's not really complicated
first you need to create a migration
file by typing super bass migration blah
blah
then you can add the SQL to your migrate
migration file sorry and then you apply
your migration okay so it's really easy
to do so imagine one day you would have
a Raspberry Pi or some computer running
there you could run your own Super Bass
instance locally on your machine and
that's what gives me the most hope in
this product is that super bass gives
you actually the power to have the full
control the full access on your database
personally I will still always use the
version on the cloud because it's really
efficient I will have no maintenance to
do but at first to test your project and
to work with Super Bass
I really advise you to create a free
project on superbass.com and if you want
to go further you can host your own
Super Bass instance on your machine
thank you very much for following this
course Please Subscribe and see you next
time bye